at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on man that's
a good intro
yeah yeah Jenny knocked that [ __ ] out of
the park yeah I know I like that I was
getting tired of the old one well we had
the old one for probably like four years
yeah two two you know yeah I just gotta
change those [ __ ] up I just had time
to do it oh sorry
the shows began and she's yawning she's
already too tired to do this I'm already
too tired today I've been up since like
seven o'clock in the morning so you know
yeah today we're gonna do a show on that
uh
the the Church of Latter-day Saints also
known as the Mormons uh but this isn't
really
it's going to do some history and we're
going to do some weird [ __ ] that went
down but this isn't really about the
mainstream Mormon church so it if you're
if you're a Mormon don't take this as an
attack against you you know your faith
you know personally because you know
I've known a lot of Mormons they're
[ __ ] great people Colonel Shea hey my
Military Academy grew up with him he was
he was Mormon
and he was a great man a lot of the [ __ ]
we're talking about here is with Mormon
sects and little Cults based on well I
mean at least one of them at least one
of them
well yeah we might get into that at the
end because I did kind of watch that
yeah that
not really talking about mainstream
Mormonism really well no we kind of are
we kind of uh was the early the early
church history yeah okay yeah I want to
get in but you know that's that's well
known you know what I mean looking uh
amongst people that study religions I
study religions I think they're great I
don't necessarily I don't believe in
them you know but I sometimes believe in
the lessons that they teach
but man there's
some people might want to pick on the
Mormons you know the cat you know the
Protestants and Baptists will pick on
the Mormons saying oh that their their
holy scriptures are ridiculous the thing
is is that y'all's scriptures are just
as ridiculous okay the way the way
scripture is generated
always starts off as heresy and then
over time it becomes you know mainstream
kind of Canon Canon for for that sex so
they all all religions have have this
this thing to them where they're kind of
hokey
but over time they become more and more
serious like they take people take it
more seriously because they become
traditional
and uh Mormonism has been around for oh
man 100 something years now
and since 1830. yeah so damn near 200
years and it's a uniquely American
religion it's really cool like in uh in
some ways uh Joseph Smith was called to
his face the the American Muhammad and
he didn't deny he goes yay because there
are a lot of there's a lot of parallels
between Joseph Smith and and uh the
prophet Muhammad they're both Prophets
uh both Talking to Angels
um in this case angel moroney
or Moroni Moroni I've heard it
pronounced both ways so I'm not really
sure which way is right my grandfather
on my mother's side you know he was he
was a scientist uh
the uh aerospace engineer but he was
also a Baptist Minister all right and I
remember him saying that with all that
it was just Moroni Moroni baloney is
what I remember he he called this
religion Moroni baloney but he believed
in some crazy [ __ ] too
all right yeah that's what I mean he
didn't have television and [ __ ] the
devil's tool the devil's box and he's
telling all the other people this he had
nine children and just ran that [ __ ]
like a damn Maximum Security Prison and
you know it was a quiverful type family
you know
and he was
a defense contractor Aerospace defense
contractor for some of the biggest
company he was smart
but he
he was half Syrian Christian his mother
was a Syrian Christian
they were running from some kind of
genocide or something that happened in
Syria
and um he was a Fundamentalist
you know became a Baptist
it's you know a Southern Baptist
[Laughter]
which uh you know they're a trip too
so we're going to be talking about
the Mormons
Jenny's got all this data on him I know
a lot about them
um but there are a lot of good Mormon
people so don't take this as an attack
against you well I mean that's kind of
true of everything like usually
um I don't usually pick on uh the people
that believe in this stuff I'm usually
just picking on the beliefs yeah because
I think it's all silly but you know yeah
and even with the Warren Jeff's cult
those poor girls and those poor dudes
poor young guys who got kicked out of
that cup because the older guys were
[ __ ] stealing all the girls
nasty you know
yeah it just seems like those kind of
groups are always just kind of like old
perverted man yeah dudes in their 80s
with with 60 wives all of a lot of them
teenagers yeah it's like that's get the
[ __ ] out of here what the [ __ ] are you
even doing yeah
it's it's messed up yeah well the thing
about it's that's interesting to me
about like I can see why this happens
because it is particularly in the United
States because it's like a
you know kind of like a competitive
Marketplace of religions yeah
um is that a lot of Christians just do
regular Garden variety Christians would
not consider Mormons Christians but
Mormons absolutely consider themselves
Christians and to be honest they yeah
the some their beliefs deviate in some
ways uh in some way in you know
sometimes wildly but I mean they still
believe in Jesus and they still believe
in like a lot of stuff that like
mainstream Christians believe in it's
not that and to be honest you know
Joseph Smith when he wrote the Book of
Mormon most of it he just lifted right
from the [ __ ] Bible you know they are
absolutely Christians absolutely and
it's mixed with a lot of stuff that
almost looks very American type stuff a
lot of it's mixed with almost kind of
masonic looking stuff well they
definitely yeah there's definitely uh
influence of the Masons yeah and then
there's uh it's a real Gnostic I mean
they can spend some wild they got some
wild ass scriptures you know what I mean
about working your way up across almost
like Scientology working your way up and
eventually being your own God where and
having to do a planet and you take you
and you'd run it the way you want to
but if everybody gets their own Planet
then who are you running
that's what I've always wanted well
you're creating your own beings
and then evidence
don't boss me around [ __ ] and
evidently the women get become kind of
like they they get promoted eventually
their souls if they're good enough to be
I guess the wife of a God so now you
have a system of kind of like Zeus and
Hera
that's a trip too but
although I feel like the I feel like the
the women in Mormons especially in the
fundamentalist Mormon sects I kind of
feel like they wouldn't have as much
power as Hera because Hera was kind of
badass like in her own right yes it just
depends on whatever Planet whatever God
you're married to
I guess so yeah I just I don't know I'm
not I'm not having it because I just I I
feel like this whole well like I said
you know not no offense to anybody but
most I mean all religions are pretty
silly to me so I'm just kind of like
stuff like this particularly Mormonism
and you know maybe not mainstream
Mormonism because they've kind of like
softened some a little bit but there is
still like a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
they do but like the fundamentalist ones
I was watching last night we watched
that uh Netflix series what's it called
keep sweet prayer and that was kind of
about the fundamentalist ones and it was
just like it was just making me so so
angry I was just like they keep sweet
was about Warren Jeff's cult yeah yeah
so I definitely want to talk a little
bit about that because we just watched
that and that that kind of [ __ ] just
makes me angry just because well because
like I said it was just obviously run by
a bunch of creepy old farts yeah using
women as trading cards yeah it's like
this is their system a barter right and
it's like do they even see they don't
even see them as people it seems like
they just kind of perceive them like
well they didn't see the boys as people
either because when they when they got
too many of them too many single Boys
around they'd fire them and kick them
out too
well they just got rid of them because
they were competition they were
competition yeah now they did keep them
around if they were if they were good at
like yeah construction or something like
that because then you could just be
slave labor it was just uh
that particular Mormon cult was just a
scam really you know uh yeah it was it
was a scam based on women young innocent
women who didn't even know what sex was
that's some wild stories between the
girls man if you haven't seen that
Netflix series that's it's something
else it's like four episodes we watched
them all last night luckily they at
least most of those girls got out of
there they're grown now and they're just
normal people [ __ ] marveling over how
what happened to them while they were in
there although that [ __ ] is still there
I think yeah yeah but Warren Jeffs is
still alive yeah and he's I mean he's in
prison but they're still there's a bunch
of them that still listen to everything
he says like they have his some of his
wives are still around and they go and
visit him in jail or write down
everything he says and be like hey this
is what the prophet said like let's do
this now but the mainstream Mormons were
normal by American Standards you know
the ones that I've known they're good
people
um uh maybe like some famous uh
characters you know from pop culture
would be in the in um in the musical
Greece San Andrew D was not from
Australia she was Mormon yeah in the
original movie yeah they just didn't
want to put that in the movie I think
well they didn't want to put that in the
movie because
I think when that movie came out I don't
really think that I I don't really think
Mormonism was like all that widespread
or widely known and I thought maybe they
thought well it's like maybe people
would think it was weird or
not enough people know about it like to
relate to it or see what we're getting
at I think they didn't want it to be
interpreted as some kind of religious
persecution or something that's you
maybe but they were just so they were
just like well it'll be more Universal
if they just make her like a general
Goody Two-Shoes yeah that that that high
school that they filmed that in they had
a statue of Myrna Loy out in front of it
my mother went to that High School uh
when she was a kid I don't remember the
name of that high school it was uh
I don't it's it's not called Rydell of
course but um that I that play was
written about California it was a
California story and it was just they
just said it there when my mom was a kid
there it was uh for the most part white
families and Mexican-American families
about half and half during during the
time she was there
um so it was actually
um not as Anglo as as as as as as
shown in in Greece it was uh half
Mexican American half Hispanic so uh
but my mother loves that loves that um
musical so do we yeah we just watched it
the other day yeah actually the other
night we watched Greece and Greece too
yeah like we did a double feature you
want to see the live TV Grease that was
good too we can watch that tonight if
we're not too drunk okay by the time
to foes in it
a lot of people wear shirts yeah a
little bit of deville yeah I really
liked the uh sorry that was the Kids in
the Hall of reference yeah um grafter's
hammer says Jack Mormons AKA Mormon men
who secretly drank and fooled around
were always a source of amusement when
old Graham lived amongst them yeah
because grandsters was saying uh when
granther lived in Oregon Mormons were a
big part of the community great
neighbors until you said no to going to
Temple with them then they didn't have
much to do with you yeah like oh you're
not a Mormon no he didn't [ __ ] with
you
you're a little bit isolated they're
kind of isolationist
which is weird because they're one of
the ones it's them and Jehovah's
Witnesses that go around knocking on
your damn doors all the time if you
don't join them then there you must be
against them that's kind of but that I
don't now I've heard of people um like
goth kids that [ __ ] lived in Salt Lake
they said that their life was hell uh if
you live in Salt Lake City uh and you're
not Mormon
they don't want you there okay uh that's
basically their City they built it which
when you look at the early
history of the of the of the more mature
yeah which we'll get it a little bit
because it's actually fascinating
there's like all kind of like Wars yeah
the Mormon Wars they were they were the
[ __ ] War they were some Warrior
Christians man and they were the United
States was hunting them down
and they were also raiding people and
non-muslims or not non-muslim non-uh
Mormons yeah but uh that all kind of
came to the end over time and there's a
lot of Mormons in Mexico a lot of people
don't know that the Mormons went down
into Mexico they're evidently still
there
yes Farmers cattle ranchers and stuff I
think I read I don't know if this is
true um the the Mormon church now say
they have about 16 17 million adherence
that's worldwide I think just very
recently because prior to that you know
because the religion started in the
United States that for a long time most
of the Mormons in the world were in the
United States but now I think that um
that that number has changed that now
like most Mormons are outside the United
States even though we still have a [ __ ]
ton here but I'm not sure if that's true
or not but it's like I'm pretty sure I
read that somewhere yeah so wild it's a
wild uh religion uh and it was
successful okay but uh their scriptures
are wild man
um it's kind of like
kind of remind me of Southern Baptists
or certain types of Southern Baptists
mixed with
Masonic rights
and new age
Spirit spiritualism or spiritism there
was yeah some kind of a culture yeah
like um
back in the 1800s you know it was real
common for real popular to get into
seances and things and to uh it had a
little bit of a veneer of that had a
little bit of a near of that
um on YouTube you can see it's leaked
out of some of their videos of them
doing rituals and making somebody a
priest and Reaching Across to uh through
a veil to shake hands and I don't know
what it's just symbolic but it looked
like a masonic right
I'm kind of cool actually you know and
the The Motif very much looks like
something out of the damn Capitol
building but it's just a very American
religion very American it was you know
in their Scriptures it says that the
that they did the ancient tribes of
Israel were here in the Americas too
back in ancient times doing all kinds of
stuff yeah yeah but yeah I mean it's a
crazy story but like I said it seemed
like
in some ways it's it's nuts like the
stuff they came up with but in the
context of the time it seemed like it
was exactly what people wanted to hear
like it came about it like just the
right time like you said it was mostly
Christian like because most of it was
just taken from the Bible or whatever
but then there was just enough of like
some other stuff like some Masonic stuff
some occult stuff some other kind of
things and it was also very specifically
American and it sort of made sense in
the context of the time because there
was some other stuff going on yeah like
some other beliefs that were going at
the time that he kind of Incorporated so
it just seemed like it got like it just
hit that sweet spot and it grew like
really really fast it also was uh kind
of rebooting and giving shout outs to
Islam like the whole concept of a
prophet who's uh speaking to an
archangel and dictating and writing down
what an archangel says as a new
scripture that happens in Mormonism yeah
the angel Moroni tells Joseph Smith
stuff and dictates to him this uh Holy
Scripture and only he can read it
because you need special glasses to read
it and it's tablets and [ __ ] it's just
hilarious maybe yeah I mean he didn't
miss a trick no no like he thought of
everything
kind of reminds me a little bit of
spiritualism the concept of automatic
writing and channeling and uh writing
down things in runes uh it was
it's so it's right there man from the
1800s that and people liked that kind of
stuff that was real cool so it was kind
of high-tech for its time yeah to fit in
fit in with the culture of the time
grandma says there is a genre of porn
called Mormon porn of course there is uh
it's fake of course but they wear the
sacred underwear and pretend to be
virgins oh [ __ ] I can see how people
would get into that like I wouldn't get
into that but I can see how people would
because it seems like ooh naughty you
know what I mean nah
go go watch that go watch that TV to go
watch that Netflix series about Warren
Jeff's cult
his Mormon cult those girls were first
of all Mormons are good looking okay
they practice selective breeding back in
the days too they're they're just kind
of a farm people and they're they're
good looking people those girls were
cute but there's nothing attract sexy
about them in terms of attractiveness
they're
me I like bad girls those girls are too
innocent they're talking about you know
what I mean and just what that's what I
mean it would be really really hard to
get nerdy well and I felt really bad for
them like especially the ones that they
interviewed on that thing like that had
gotten out and it's like they were born
in it they didn't know any different
yeah and it's so like when they escaped
and I have to say like some of those
women some of those and they were just
girls when they left some of them were
just teenagers they were like yeah I'm
out and they just like [ __ ] walked
out and it's just like they didn't know
anything about the World At Large or
anything can you imagine the [ __ ]
giant Bratz balls it takes you to do
that holy [ __ ] in Mississippi you had
these people call Mennonites and to me
they reminded me of Mennonites they had
just their hairstyles were just
extremely out of fashion just clothes
handmade clothes that were extremely
dull and out of fashion and
you know like
you'll see what I'm talking about I mean
[Laughter]
well that one ugly clothes
I'm not saying that it's just that it's
obvious that they're they're religious
clothes you know I mean it's obvious to
me they look kind of like cowgirl
outfits but with long skirts it's 1800s
looking yeah pastel colors
a lot of Ruffles and [ __ ]
um well Warren Jeff said they had to
have like particular braids yeah they
even had little videos where they showed
you how to do all the different braid
styles that were acceptable bouffant
looking things and just
because he wanted he wanted everybody to
have a perfect oval face yeah and so you
had to do your hair slightly different
like depending on what your face shape
was and I'm like dude you were thinking
way too much about this [ __ ] would have
been out of fashion even in the 1800s
it'd be like man that's some tacky [ __ ]
you know
I just can't I can't
hang with people that are just that have
all these real rigid yeah I can't hang
with rigid people you know what I mean
like I can hang with people that have
different beliefs than me or that or
whatever that's cool but it's just like
I don't know I I people that are just
have any kind of rigidity and they're
like well we can't do that or we can't
think about that or we can't say that or
something like that I don't know I have
I have a hard time like relaxing around
people yeah what they were trying to do
was trying to Homage
1950s Style country clothes
okay
if you ever see an old movie from the
70s when they'd show a redneck you know
they're wearing old-fashioned like 50s
type country clothes there's you'll know
exactly what what it is I'm talking
about
like [ __ ] kind of like the tacky
Cowboy shirts and [ __ ]
it's just the female versions of that
and they're they're homage and 50s
country clothes in in the
2000s
and
I don't know why they're image in that
time period because that's not the way
the 1800s were were the Genesis of
of Mormonism you know they actually
probably would have been wearing a lot
of black and a lot of brown
and it would have been
survivalists closed on the planes
Cowboys it looked like Gunslingers I
feel like you yeah that would look a lot
cooler if you were like a really
Nephilim yeah with the [ __ ] like
dudes from the fields or that looked
like Quakers or yeah like with the big
like round crown hats and like the black
kind of like that would look awesome
well it would have it was eight 1830s
and 1800s they would look more like it
feels dudes from the fields of the
Nephilim flat round adds a flat on top
yeah see how [ __ ] around They Carried
guns and [ __ ] they fought a lot all
right so
they didn't have that 1950s Disney
[ __ ] generic look yeah I'm curious as
to like where that specific
look came from because like idealizing
the past Yeah well yeah I know it's like
a lot of people do that but it's just
kind of like whenever you see the
Mormons well because actually
um you know they'll go around with their
little the little guys that go around
you know doing the the door-to-door
thing and they go around their little
bicycles with their little crisp white
shirts and their little black ties and
their little black
slacks and [ __ ] like that and it's I'm
not really sure
why like why that particular look and
particularly like I said with the with
the women like why did they want to look
like they all want to look like Laura
Mormon woman of the 1800s was probably
wearing a black Victorian style dress
that was long and probably a bonnet
you cut it Todd but that's basically
what women wore they wore a lot of black
so trial it was
nowadays you'd look at her dude
you know you guys know what I'm talking
about
yeah I don't I mean I don't know so much
about
you know mainstream Mormons they seem
like and even when we were watching the
documentary about the Warren Jeffs you
know the the FD the flds or whatever
um they kind of were not what we would
consider normal clothes but normal for
them clothes like some of them like just
looked like they were wearing normal
[ __ ] they didn't really look like
they said as long as you were covered up
it didn't really matter what you were
but like once Warren Jeffs came in and
it got like super strict then everybody
had to wear these very specific
dresses and then once he moved to that
other like compound he wanted everybody
to wear pastel colors
like depending it was very Logan's Run
it seemed like I don't know if it was
age
could you pick what pastel because it
kind of looked like
had like an age categories where it's
like oh if you're 20 to 25 you have to
wear like pastel pink and like this age
has to wear like pastel yellow or
something like that because they had
like different colors but I couldn't
really figure out what the what the
uh they would just use whatever random
pastel material they had I guess but
it's I don't know it was just very
strange it's very strange like I said
I you know I I don't have a problem with
people
um you know joining that kind of [ __ ]
and we talked about this when we talk
about scientology look if you're an
adult and you want to join Scientology I
don't know why the [ __ ] you would want
to
but okay fair enough you know it's it's
your life if you want to [ __ ] it up
that's up to you but the problem arises
when you got kids in that [ __ ] and they
don't really have a choice you know what
I mean yeah I know to an extent like if
you have a kid you're their parent
you're gonna raise them in whatever
religion you think is the right one and
blah blah and obviously you should to an
extent you should have a right to do
that but when they get 18 they want to
leave you can't stop them I don't
believe in that disconnection policy
yeah that's what that is totally well
you're 18 you can move out and the
Mormons kind of do that too well at
least I talk to you at least the
fundamentalisms do I don't know about
the major because because like I said
when I say the Mormons you know
obviously it's just like any other
religious group where there's like lots
of different right sects and it's like
some of them are more
strict than others you know what I mean
so some of them wouldn't do that
necessarily yeah they can still hang
with like non-mormon family members and
some of them were like absolutely not
like obviously the fundamentalist ones
they're fundamentalist for a reason you
leave and they're like okay well we're
not talking to you ever again you're
like disfellowshipped I think they call
it we had a Mormon squad leader in the
Army named Sergeant back and started
back with married and had kids and it
was just a normal family and he was
popular in the platoon and was just a
regular guy yeah that's the cop the most
that's the most common one yeah I wasn't
from Utah or anything yeah from
somewhere else yeah I kind of feel well
I mean they're associated with Utah
because that's their spread that's kind
of their headboard headquarters just
kind of like you know Clearwater
Scientology headquarters but that
doesn't mean that that's where all of
them are though they're all kind of all
over the world Howard Hughes like the
Mormons his whole security and
intelligence operation to protect him
because he had his own private Army
basically in his own intelligence group
they were all Mormons he liked them
because they didn't smoke they were
trustworthy and had good morals and uh
they tolerated the fact that those
Mormons that would tolerate the fact
that he had multiple girlfriends
and because they were like hey plural
okay he's like us we do that too yeah
they don't all do that but you know what
I mean yeah actually the mainstream
Mormon church they uh they stop doing
that yeah
um mostly because they got in trouble
for it but I kind of feel like they just
Generations have gone by now the younger
ones kind of see that as anything but
the fundamentalists still absolutely
yeah right and here's the thing I was
thinking about this when we were
watching the [ __ ] last night obviously
the [ __ ] that went down at the Warren
Jeff's compound that [ __ ] was [ __ ] up
because most of those girls were
teenagers they were like he was marrying
girls that were like 14 and [ __ ] and
they found out later on that Warren
Jeffs was actually essentially raping 14
12 year old girls they had audio they
found audio of it yeah he was a pedo
yeah he you look at him and you can see
that in him there's just something about
his face there's something not right
about him he's got that opito face you
know pedo face Pito face yeah that's
what I mean it's like we were watching
that last night I'm like God every
single one of the dudes in here looks
like a creep like you can tell like
they're a creepiest man if they were
normal they got kicked out because
getting that story they rebelled against
Jeff's some of them did like I say right
they kicked them all out yeah
but that yeah it's I don't know but they
didn't have a backup plan
they should have been a straight up
Revolt like look man this is going to
stop or we're going to overthrow you and
as soon as he said something crazy you
just beat his ass I mean he didn't have
any physical power he was a tall weak
guy I mean if you had enough people to
do that but see that's the yeah you only
well when you're about 10 and some guns
right I'm just saying that but when you
because I think what a lot of people
don't realize like it's hard for me to
intellectualize it too just because I
don't yeah I don't know like I don't
think this way but when you've been in a
group for a long time or when you were
raised in it I think the biggest hurdle
is the mental hurdle yeah it's mental
more than anything we should like oh my
God because they they interviewed like a
lot of the girls like that you know that
are now women that left and they were
like just freaking out like it took them
a really long time to realize hey I
could just leave and then like when that
occurred to them it was like terrifying
because they had never really been in
the real world before they didn't know
anything about it they didn't know where
they were gonna go they didn't know they
thought the whole world was evil that's
what they've been taught it's a lot like
Scientology yeah I mean well they're all
kind of similar so it's like they didn't
really know they're like what you know
what do I do what do I do if I get out
in the real world and I'm by myself and
the world is as evil as I've been taught
that it is like they didn't really know
so I mean overcoming that has to be like
really [ __ ] because that goes against
like every single thing that you've ever
been taught you know it's [ __ ] up
uh Larry and creature said I'm all for
religious ideas and spiritualism it's
cool to think about but as soon as it
crosses over into strict rules and
regulations and super rigid definitions
of unknowable things you lose me yeah
I'm I'm about on the same page of that
mr88 said yeah raising children in any
religion is brainwashing I mean it is to
a certain extent uh most adults do not
understand the complexities of religious
lore let alone impressionable children
yeah I mean it's [ __ ] up like I said
yeah that's your kid and yeah you're
gonna raise them in the way that you
think is correct and to an extent that
should be allowed but
I also don't have a problem with because
here's the thing the Warren Jeff's thing
in particular when they rated that
compound
um the Mormon Church were very were at
least the F LDS they were very
successful in getting
um public sympathy on their side because
they're like look the feds just came in
here and took all these kids what was it
like 400 something kids or something
like that out of the compound because a
few people had escaped and said hey
there's like underage they're marrying
off underage girls and there's like all
kind of like statutory rape so they went
in there and they just pulled them all
out because they were like they didn't
know and so I'm sitting there going I
really I don't know what I would have
done in that situation it seems like
there's no winning you go in there and
pull all those kids out I mean that
probably is the best thing for them but
then in another way
that's all those kids know and it's like
is this really I don't know it's just
it's really [ __ ] up I'm sure there was
like a lot more widespread abuse going
on in that [ __ ] than we even know about
so Samantha in there got my back that's
right it was called Venice High School
that's that's where uh Greece was oh
okay film that's where my mother went to
high school Venice High School had Myrna
Lloyd standing out there they kept
breaking her arms off
the damn statue and had to then they got
to where they stopped [ __ ] replacing
them
but um that's where that's where that
movie was near there was where uh Muscle
Beach and was Gold's Gym and
Arnold Schwarzenegger and all those guys
came out of that Fitness the Gold's Gym
there right there near Muscle Beach so
you know what was different back then
that was when everything was new
well from our point of view everything
was new
yeah Ben said Howard Hughes liked the
Mormons because of their purity
stupidity and they were handy for
transfusions I wouldn't say stupid they
weren't stupid I think a lot of Mormons
joined the Secret Service yeah
yeah maybe they do well what they they
they they
have a lot of good things about them
that promote loyalty okay and another
thing that happened is that uh
Howard Hughes was good to the Mormon
church
you know I think over the time he
shifted money to him
and uh when he died it seems that
a lot of the Hughes estate went to Salt
Lake City after that now whether or not
he knew
it's unknown because there is there's a
possibility that his intelligence
Services may have just shifted the money
over there after he died it's unknown
I'm just gonna say I don't know if I
entirely trust people that
um are like won't drink coffee or tea
every Mormon I knew was in real life
[ __ ] did
they drag it yeah that's what I mean I
just so I kind of feel like yeah that's
something that's like you know obviously
they don't drink alcohol which you know
like I said that's fair enough
um you know I'm I'm a drunk but that's
fine
um I know some people don't like to
drink and I'll you know if you like to
drink fine if you don't like to drink
fine I'm like I'm fine with it but it's
just like I don't know I mean I it's not
for me because I love coffee I love
booze
um so it's like I I just don't see
myself
um you know and and I don't really want
to be the 65th wife of some 85 year old
pervert either most of most of the
Mormons I knew
weren't real strict because they were in
the Army now I went to high school one
Molly Molly Day High School in Brazil
with her and her dad was kind of like
the uh the the Mormon equivalent of like
a bishop or something he was in charge
of all the operations happening in
Brazil that time she went to the
International High School with us
and uh she was my date for the prom
and the Mormons weren't all that happy
about that but Molly was gorgeous I got
pictures of her uh we ended up being the
prom keg and queen we got voted in
but uh I don't know I probably got a
picture over probably my pictures but
she was a Mormon yeah she was religious
all right that was the same that was a
real life Sandra d but she wasn't my
girlfriend though just I just asked her
for the problem she said yeah
that's all
right you're bad influence on her she
probably but she she wouldn't drink and
uh no coffee no no uh caffeinated soda
or anything but you know so
you know [ __ ] she's I'm sure she she
got married a long time ago she's
probably back in Salt Lake you know
but no she was she was a good girl she
was
she was orthodox
and that's the thing it's like when I
was growing up I wasn't like a big
drinker or a drug addict or nothing like
that but it's just kind of like it just
sounds like not just because not because
I was like oh I don't believe in it it
was just kind of like I don't really
feel like it right now like I started
drinking later on but I was just kind of
like I don't really understand I don't
know it just seems like no fun you know
what I mean it seems like no fun
yeah I don't think Molly thought it was
all that fun either it's not really fun
yeah Larry and creature said what is
that orange potion you guys are always
sipping on this is vodka orange juice
and grenadine a little bit of grenadine
so it's a screwdriver essentially yeah
screwdriver a little bit of grenadine a
little bit of grenadine in it yeah okay
look I got a picture of me and Molly
that's me and Molly at the prom
that was a Mormon princess right there
yeah I got a top hat on
got top hat and tails
yeah
you see that
yeah I've seen that picture we used to
have that hanging in the closet for
years and years oh yeah I guess it did
yeah yeah you did
um let's see Dave Rowling said why did
the Mormon cross the road to get to the
other bride
that's such a dad joke but it's so funny
um
now see John Smith said it's not just
coffee and tea it's any hot drink I
never heard that because I thought it
was caffeine
that they didn't drink because they
thought that it was kind of like a drug
or something which I guess technically
it is but come on
yeah uh yeah he says caffeine is one
factor but no hot drinks whatsoever put
in by Joseph Smith himself huh
all right like I'd heard a lot of weird
stuff about them but and I thought I had
heard all the weird stuff but I found
one weird fact today and I don't really
know if it's true or not but we'll get
into that in a minute you can ask and
who was in the back that was the MC he's
back there with the microphone talking
about the couples and [ __ ] we were
getting voted in we had gotten voted in
we were accepting like the is that the
end of the ceremony we're becoming like
prom king and queen getting all the
[ __ ] gifts and [ __ ] and then somebody
dumped Pig's blood on her
I know that didn't happen it's just a
joke
it's like no not really I'm like yeah I
know not really it's called a joke
uh but yeah oh I wanted to say I think I
said this on one of the um
movie reviews but I always like to do it
on the main show but we have a new
Patron named Tyron so thank you very
much next time
uh like I said I'm pretty sure I didn't
mention it because I think it happened
like in the last week so I mentioned it
on the movie review yeah we're looking
for new patrons over the years we've
lost a lot of patrons a patronage went
down by 50 percent
over about two or three year periods so
we know it's hard out there
but uh if you guys can help out Jenny
this is Jenny's only source of income
selling books and super chats and AD
revenue and the and the occasional
graphic design you're right
that uh 600 bucks a month patronage
really did help out when it dropped down
to 300 we felt it Yeah well yeah you
know so I keep we're looking for new
patrons it's like a phantom hair it's
like that's the thing was like wearing
these wearing this hair man I'm gonna
refresh the drinks why don't you go
ahead and uh start the show okay
so yeah I bet well okay
yeah perhaps they collectively backslide
on the hot beverage issue because I've
never heard it yeah I haven't either I I
thought it was just capping I'm not
saying you're wrong I'm just saying um
I've only heard that it was caffeine but
you know I don't know that much about
them but like I said holy [ __ ] like no
hot chocolate no yeah [ __ ] that
I don't think I would want to live any
kind of life I could live without booze
I mean it wouldn't it would kind of be a
miserable life because I do like booze
but I could live without it if some you
know if like a doctor said to me it's
like you really have to stop drinking or
or whatever then I'd be like okay I
wouldn't like it but I could do it but
if they came to me and said you can't
have coffee or tea or hot chocolate even
what the [ __ ] kind of life is that what
kind of life is that I ask you I just I
don't know I don't know
uh you know it seems there's a lot of
similarities between Scientology and the
Mormons both creators had very specific
and weird ass dictations yeah I was
actually thinking that when I was
researching this show and when we were
watching keep sweet last night on
Netflix I was just kind of like there
are a lot of parallels between Mormonism
and
Scientology I mean they came at it from
slightly different things but it was
basically like well we're going to take
a foundation of something that already
kind of exists and then we're just gonna
like put our own spin on it so it's kind
of like that
um and John Smith said I don't know but
it's listed on the LDS website is it
really
huh
okay so here's here's the fact that I
just because
um I forgot to go look at their official
website to see if this is actually on
there I just saw it on another website
and I was like wait what I never heard
that
are they really do they really think
that
um
that Satan like is in bodies of water
so like they're kind of discouraged from
maybe like boating and swimming and
stuff like that because it's like
they're afraid they're gonna get
Satan cooties or something I'd actually
never heard that before and I was just
kind of like what but then like the rest
of the stuff in the list was I was like
okay that's legit I've heard that but
it's like I never heard that water thing
ever
I don't know but like I said I probably
should have checked the official website
but I didn't have time I was going
through like because man I went to like
um
I watched like a whole bunch of
documentaries about it like I said watch
the Netflix ones there's one we talked
we I don't remember if we talked about
this before but we talked about that one
that's about what's that dude's name
Mark Hoffman that guy that was um
forging like all the Mormon stuff and uh
blew up some people so we want to talk
about him as well there's also a
documentary about him on Netflix called
Murder among the Mormons which is
actually really good which we watched a
while back
but you know
Lars Ulrich said I read Romney's
favorite book was Battlefield Earth or
something one of the Harvard books
anyway
yeah I I kind of feel like they're very
similar they're very similar
so you know
[Laughter]
yeah John Smith said hot drinks are not
for the body or belly Doctrine and
Covenants well that's official because
yeah Joseph Smith wrote that
huh interesting
satanic bodies of water no in every
single rock song ever yes yeah lyric
creature said Satan has pretty awesome
Taste of music I agree he does Ben said
early Mormonism was a string of Bank
frauds yeah that's another thing that a
lot of people don't know yeah and scams
yeah I mean well construction scams are
[ __ ] clearly there was all kind of [ __ ]
about that I mean you know it's what I
get into because I just have like a very
basic timeline and then maybe we can
elaborate on stuff like as we go on
yeah Brigham Young had a chest of fake
silver ingots they kept moving because
lynch mobs are always after them
dry money yeah they yeah I mean
clearly I'm not really sure
I don't know I don't know if I know
enough about Joseph Smith to just say
that he was just like a scam artist but
the [ __ ] that he did sounds very much
like a scam artist like it sounds
absolutely like he knew what he was
doing you know
Church of scamming people well it didn't
have anything to do with Mormonism per
se there's just a long history of
churches scamming people
didn't matter what the denomination
and the Mormon's [ __ ] scammed man
yeah they scramble their way to the top
it was very scary in the early years
they didn't have any money you know I
mean so there's always a justification
we don't have any money and we got to
Spread spread God's word and we have to
multiply our numbers we're gonna need
money so we're gonna get this done we're
gonna take it from the heathen
you know yeah take it from these
non-believers
mr88 said I'll say it for you who was
just a scam artist yeah I mean the [ __ ]
that he came up with
like I said the whole thing about we'll
get into that with the whole Golden
Plates and all that yeah I mean
everything he came up with just sounds
like
it just sounds like a big [ __ ] scam
and I think he was totally totally aware
of what he was doing
all you got to do is just read old and
Newton Newt all you gotta do is read Old
and New Testament scriptures and you're
gonna have everything you need right
there to learn how to [ __ ] replicate
those kind of stories
guarantee okay if some dude Dave Moses
ever went to Atop A Mountain he came
down with some damn
stone tablets okay come on think about
this just think about this
all right that's all I'm gonna say about
that I mean it sounds cool like now that
we've because we've grown up with that
yeah that was thousands of years ago
this dude goes but if somebody did that
nowadays God was talking to me I gotta
write these things down everybody be
like put down that golden calf God damn
it
he broke through the originals he broke
the originals when he saw him but but
people forget about that but he broke
the originals he had to go back up there
and get get new ones hey hey god um yeah
yeah I dropped yeah this is what nice
thing can I have a new set
okay but be a lot more careful with
these ones okay he's down with new
Commandments
I love that story thank you granthers
Mormons tithe every week so does Graham
thank you very much yeah that's another
thing that you're supposed to give is it
it's ten percent right they're tithing
yeah it's ten percent and they have to
get even if you're even if you're
pregnant even if you're broke dick yeah
and the and much like Scientology
um the Mormons have like billions and
billions of dollars of Revenue you know
gotta keep those airplanes flying
I guess so I'm Gonna Keep Those temples
being got it yeah we got to keep
building those temples and [ __ ] like
that holy crap I was watching that like
Warren Jeff's thing last night and when
they finally got into the temple which
actually was I was like wow that I
wonder how much that [ __ ] took to build
that's like some fancy [ __ ] in there and
they had like a whole like Vault that's
where all the evidence of the perverted
[ __ ] was which I was like sitting there
thinking you guys are [ __ ] idiots
like why would you save all that [ __ ] I
guess so he could go back and watch it
later but still but he knew it was bad
because he's like oh I'm Gonna Keep It
In The Vault they had a [ __ ] Vault
they opened the Vault they're like oh
here's all the evidence right here that
was easy yeah Jesus Christ why did they
save that kind of [ __ ] and he had like
all right later well Andy had like all
the records of all the underage
marriages like it was all written down
right there and they're just like oh
well thank you yeah you know he knew it
was bad like I don't know why he written
all that I don't know I guess it was a
good thing he was stupid because they
sent him to prison but for some reason
they're just hell-bent on keeping
records
yeah that's if I was justified there
might justify their power
maybe that's what it is like because I
can't really think of any smart person
reason I mean there's I don't know if
you're trying to be they're trying to be
official yeah well they didn't see
themselves as as an Earthly outfit
you know they were saying that the
federal government and the uh and the
state that the the state government had
nothing to do with them and it didn't
they were in another country basically
it wasn't until later that they got him
yeah he realized oh I guess we do have
to follow these other people's laws God
damn it that's the thinking
well I kind of feel like they still
don't because I mean it's different
nowadays like after the raid and
everything but
the whole war and Jeff's thing they had
that town uh short Creek they kept
saying the creek that's what they called
it short Creek a short Creek and um they
owned that whole town Warren Jeff's one
they they owned all the cops they owned
and basically like you couldn't come in
there and tell them to do [ __ ] because
it's like they're just like hey this is
our town and you can't tell us to do
anything they would select who was going
to be a policeman yeah so they were all
in you know it's all occult the whole
damn City the Old Town yeah crazy it's
like some [ __ ] out of a movie I mean it
wasn't a massive City or anything but
still it was sprawling it sprawled out
yeah I mean that's all [ __ ] up
Mr 88 said while I have a soft spot for
Mormons the Mormon leadership is like
slave Traders yeah they are kind of
corporate vipers and pathological Liars
rolled into one yeah
that's gonna happen so kind of like
scientologists yeah very very similar
there's a lot of similarities and the
baker Empire Tammy Tammy Faye and and
man we should do a show about that yeah
there was a whole other [ __ ] and that
was kind of pulled out of the Hat they
just made that on their own
but you're always it's gonna kind of
gravitate towards that kind of behavior
if you're a good person you're not going
to end up at the Top If you're a good
person you won't end up at the top only
the ruthless ones yeah only the worst
ones yeah at the top that's just how it
works because there's power there and a
psychopath wants that power yeah so and
they're willing to whereas a person with
a conscience like so we won't let
somebody wouldn't do certain things like
to get power but like somebody like
that'll that would do absolutely
anything yep we were wondering because
Tom was wondering we were watching that
uh documentary last night he's like do
you think that they actually like
murdered anybody that I was like you
know what
it wouldn't Shock Me I'm not saying but
I mean you had to have proof that
somebody went missing that's what I mean
they don't have any evidence of that but
I said if they did come forward and say
hey like these people were missing and
it's like maybe there's some bodies or
something that would not Shock Me In
This latest I've heard there were some
other programs that I saw that involved
similar you know similar Mormon sex but
they were they were the Cults they
weren't the mainstream ones where um I'm
trying to I don't remember any names
from it
um but no uh
if a girl ran evidently they killed her
see that sound it to me it sounds like
something that they would do yeah
because they didn't want to go into the
authorities type of deal right but some
girls did run and they didn't have any
proof it's just that they had heard that
they killed that girl so I don't know if
it's true or not you know but like I
said it wouldn't surprise me right it
wouldn't surprise me because that same
kind of deal dude I'm in that track
Trading older guys basically trading
younger women for as wives basically was
the whole thing and then you had the
older women were kind of like the
enforcers over the young ones
you know weird [ __ ] you know what I mean
that was yeah that whole thing was
[ __ ] up that um actually I think it
was 1980s or something yeah well Warren
Jeff's dad uh uncle rulon or whatever
his name was he had that was his so he
had brought in that whole keep sweet
thing which was basically like it was
like oh you know the women are all
supposed to be like sweet and
accommodating and everything like that I
was like basically it means shut your
[ __ ] mouth [ __ ] like we can do
whatever the hell we want and you're not
allowed to complain about it that's
essentially what that was they were very
ignorant yeah though they didn't know
anything
they didn't even know anything about sex
they didn't know anything about mating
rituals or anything you know yeah they
were when they married those girls off
then they were teenagers sex was yeah
like the guy started like the old fart
started doing that and they were like
what the [ __ ] are you doing I said like
a dude rolled over to me and started and
he's like what the [ __ ] is this is bad
well yeah because that's what they've
been telling me their whole lives that
this is like a bad thing yeah it's like
why are you doing this to me now like so
I don't know she's like 15 kissing this
90 year old man and he's putting a big
old lip lock on her and [ __ ] [ __ ]
that and then Jenny you're getting
grossed out I know it's like well they
had like photos of it and I was like God
look at those poor girls like they look
so [ __ ] good they're just like yeah
you yeah it's like the dude's like 85.
you've got 60 wives he's got all the
women and all the young ones God yeah
it's [ __ ] up man
he goes against nature
goes against nature like [ __ ]
potentates and [ __ ] successful dudes
had harems
but for the most part they were kind of
slightly age-appropriate at least and a
lot of those guys didn't live long
anyway
guys that had Arabs back in in in Asia
history they were dead by 50 something
so you know they weren't putting those
girls through something so unnatural you
know 15 with a 90 year old dude yeah
yeah it's pretty NE and you know that's
[ __ ] it's bad enough that it's like
he's [ __ ] 85 but he's also like he's
just like a [ __ ] creeper man yeah
it's like it's the whole thing is so
creepy
yeah and none of them nobody's sexy no
nobody
[Laughter]
it's hard to be sexy in those outfits
none of the dudes are all that sexy no
none of them
everybody nerdy real nerdy well there's
nothing even wrong with nerdy nerdy can
be sexy too but it's just kind of like
that kind of not that kind of nerdy and
that's like more incel creeper nerdy
you know what I mean it was [ __ ] some
retro [ __ ] man it is very rich round
so okay religious people are just not
sexy sorry people
well like I said it's just because it's
hard to like hang with somebody that you
don't really know like they have these
very very strict
a very strict world view or a very
strict and like they can't go outside of
that I just have a hard time like
relating to people like that that's all
I'm not saying you can't be like that
you can but it's just kind of like I
find it difficult to uh converse with
people like that like if there's
areas where you're not allowed to go or
I'm not allowed to do this or I'm not
you know like I said if you're if you
don't do something for you know health
reasons that's fine but it's just like
if you're just like well uh you know a
magical Sky fairy told me not to drink
any coffee then I'm then we're gonna
have a problem UFO cult people are more
sexy than this one these people they're
just something always kind of like
delayed
stunted growth feeling about the people
when you're talking about yeah it's like
they're
perpetual
12 year olds or something yeah and
there's nothing sexy about it yeah
except to Warren Jeffs apparently but
he's a straight up pedo that's what I
mean he's a truck of Peter Christ they
should they played some of that audio
too I don't think you were in the room
monopolyed like they didn't play the
worst [ __ ] but you could imagine it and
I'm sitting there you know Jesus Christ
dude ugh
that [ __ ] is still in prison too but
somebody yeah but yeah he's still in
prison he's still alive but um yeah but
like I said some of them still like he's
still got followers like they still
listen to him yeah he hasn't worn off
yet
God that's like that's so sad to me it's
so sad to me I hope like some of those
people are just like what the [ __ ] am I
doing with my life you know what I mean
but
I know it's like scary I know it's scary
to leave and I really admire like the
people that got out of there especially
the people that were raised in it
because they you know they they never
experienced anything different so they
wouldn't know
you know what to do if they got out so
that's like really ballsy but you know
yeah they're asking questions about the
Mormons yeah Mormons can eat fast food
as far as I know they own fast food
corporations I think they own Dairy
Queen I think oh do they yeah I think
that's Mormons
at least it was at one time yeah maybe I
don't know if they own it anymore
because I thought Dairy Queen was maybe
owned by like a larger
conglomeration and one time I think they
I think but I could be totally wrong
about that you guys can check that but I
always heard that
Dairy Queen was Mormon yeah I don't
think they have a problem with that like
like I said the mainstream Mormon church
is especially nowadays I think they've
softened on some of their views I'm not
saying that there's not still like
rampant abuse going on in there and
actually like just a couple years back
there was like a huge thing where a lot
of them were like abusing uh Boy Scouts
and stuff but you know they got sued a
lot over that but
I don't know I kind of feel like
somebody pointed out it's different
between Mormons and and LDS Latter-Day
Saints LDS is there is like out of Utah
and that's their Orthodox Church
you know he's talking about the
fundamentals the fundamentalists LDS
that's what I'm saying that's their
Orthodox Church yes
um the most the ones we're talking about
now are what they call Breakaway sex
from the LDS
it's it's not it's they're not the same
there's a whole bouquet of [ __ ]
Mormon roses each one of them a little
bit different yeah because there are
even some more kind of like liberal sex
yeah that are not real strict right and
other rules or they're just cultural
Mormons yeah cultural Mormons they broke
away from it and they're just living
well like I said just like any other
Christian sex because they are
essentially like a Christian sect even
though I think a lot of Christians would
be mad about that but they're not that
different really no I don't think about
the same
from it I mean from an objective
standpoint their beliefs are not really
that much different from mainstream
Christianity honestly no not that much
different really no the the scriptures
are different but they're wild you know
what I mean I like them do I believe
them no but I don't I don't believe the
Orthodox stuff either you know yeah
I don't believe in DC or Marvel I don't
believe yeah I don't I don't care about
[ __ ] Superman fan fiction if it's
good then I still it's still Superman to
me
Spirit of the original Focus Superman is
good you know and some of the stuff that
the
that the Mormons believed in was it's a
it's a reboot you know and retellings or
um
what you call expanded universe that's
what you would know it in like the uh in
the Star Wars type yeah yeah [ __ ]
scenes it's expanded you know it's a
Christian expanded universe literature
I mean that's how I always kind of saw
it I was like well it's 95 Christian
which is like five percent of some other
[ __ ] in it yeah you know what I mean
with their own inventions in their own
stories
which you know like I said maybe
Christians be mad like because to them
like I kind of feel like most mainstream
Christians feel like Mormonism is like a
cult
which
certain denominations I guess absolutely
are like that one like the Warren Jeff's
one but I mean that's absolutely a cult
it's a denomination of Christianity like
being Catholic or Protestant and then
there's Mormons yeah that's that's the
number that's weird but like I said from
my point of view it's all weird so it's
all weird it's all weird it's okay so
I'm not really like all that about it
yeah that's what you know the Catholics
call themselves the one true church that
all they asked they all do the Catholics
are saying everybody else are [ __ ]
everybody else well the Mormons say that
too yeah I was watching there's actually
a really good um documentary if you want
just like a really good hour and a half
like overview of Mormonism uh there's
it's on free on YouTube and I think it's
just called Mormons who they are and
what they believe or something like that
and it's really good it's like in
several like chapters so I watched that
earlier today and they had a woman on
there who was raised in Mormonism and
she absolutely she's like yeah they
absolutely think that they're the one
true religion that's the only one and
like I said I had their own profits
right that's what I'm saying it's the
same with Islam it has its own Prophet
yeah but it is an offshoot of
Christianity I mean it's got Jesus in
its scriptures and stuff it's
but it's it's it's still
um what do you call a god of Abraham
okay it's got Jesus in it yeah but it
now has a new prophet
but it's a new source of scripture and a
new law supposed to be supposed to be a
completion of Judaism and Christianity
that's what Mormonism claims
yeah times the same [ __ ] thing right
so like I said a very similar very
similar
both prophets are dictating the words of
an archangel it's just two different
archangels yeah so the the so hey I mean
if you're making all these shut up then
it's in it who are you to say that one's
right and the other one's not right it's
not like you prove it just saying
grabther says if a couple of 19 year
olds riding bikes wearing white shirts
of black ties knocked on your door would
you let them in for a nice conversation
over cookies juice no absolutely not
they are not coming in my house dude I'm
too busy with porn
you got lube you don't have a go ahead
and they won't come in I guarantee you
want to watch some porn
you want to Star on some porn I got my
camera
fans awaits we got to make money in this
bit and they would run okay you have to
learn they don't want to come to our
house yes
how to manipulate others by using their
fears yeah
yeah
my my over two windows highly expanded
everything is weaponized to come at me
I'm gonna [ __ ] come with you all
right you're not ready for this
I haven't had any I haven't had Mormons
come to my door for like a really long
time they're not here in Florida as far
as I can tell they're not frostilizing
here
I don't know if that's entirely the case
now I haven't seen one I have had
Jehovah's Witnesses yeah big difference
come to my door useless the Jehovah
Witnesses are useless but and I've known
some Jehovah's Witnesses like I worked
with some yeah
um I think they're I mean there are some
Mormons around I'm sure but you don't
really see them all that much one Mormon
is worth five Jehovah's Witnesses in my
in my mind like I know about this I know
about the jokes I'll end up with like I
don't know you know obviously it's just
kind of another thing where you know
it's probably really similar but the
Jehovah's Witnesses all I knew about
them I remember learning about them like
when I was in maybe fifth or sixth grade
because a kid in my class
he was a Jehovah's Witness or his
parents made him be a Jehovah's Witness
like that's you know because he was too
young to pick really yeah but um
everybody felt he was like the nicest
kid ever but it's like everyone felt
sorry for him because Jehovah's
Witnesses they don't celebrate any
holidays yeah so it's like every time
like it was somebody's birthday and
you'd bring some cupcakes or some [ __ ]
like that or every time it was like
Halloween and people come or Valentine's
Day or whatever he had to go sit in the
teacher's lounge and we were like man
that is some [ __ ] right there what
the [ __ ] kind of stupid religion is this
if you go on either bit shoot or uh
Rumble and go look for a channel called
the hard bastard all right it is funny
as [ __ ] and that is a channel being run
by an ex Jehovah's Witness
and what he does is all he does is just
analyze news and mainstream media
and he uses
uh uh Jehovah Witnesses he Compares
everything to to his time in the
Jehovah's Witness all right and how
Cults think uh and
he's fascinating he's real funny he's
called the hard bastard
he'll talk he'll go off of he'll go on
and on about Jehovah's Witness about how
their Elders were so incompetent all
right and that would they could never
get anything done and everything was
Ultra passive and the whole thing about
the Jehovah's Witnesses was basically
just to hide crimes committed by people
in the church that's all it did you know
I kind of feel like that's true of a lot
of religions
some dude molested and his daughter the
church knows all about it they're not
gonna say anything that's that's that's
that's all that happens in Mormonism too
that's what all it is that's yeah let's
not say anything we won't say anything
we won't do anything or look bad on the
church so we gotta hide this we gotta
hide this yeah that's that's and that's
yeah look at all that and that yeah a
lot of that there was a big Scandal a
few years back because of Mormonism and
obviously like going back years and
years the Catholic church with all that
molestation and stuff like that and they
knew about it and they just like moved
the priests around and all that kind of
[ __ ] and then whenever a problem happens
that threatens the church they just said
well we'll think about it we'll pray on
it and of course there's never any
solution no solution ever yeah they
never do anything there's no action
nothing any and that's why I say that
you know one Mormon is worth five
Jehovah's Witness because at least the
Mormons did [ __ ] okay Jehovah's
Witnesses don't do anything they just
hide things well no the Mormons do that
too yes the Mormons but the Mormons do
things Mormons build things
why does that make them better though
well at least they're doing something
they're they're actually doing something
yeah they're also molesting he said
they're not doing [ __ ] he says he said
that the Jehovah's Witnesses did nothing
nothing they said they're just a bunch
of old people in their 80s and 90s that
don't take any action on anything they
just say well we'll pray on it
maximum incompetence is what he said
granther says Mormon's own huge
corporate farming operations in Florida
North Carolina and other states oh do
they okay there you go
uh Ben says they made a movie with Kevin
Sorbo
in Melbourne sorry I laugh at Kevin
Zorba um he's in all those like shitty
wasn't he in [ __ ] uh uh God's Not
Dead wasn't he in that yeah that's a
horrible [ __ ] thing uh yeah in
Melbourne about Mormon missionaries
coming to teach the Australians
basketball it was an okay movie but the
director was jailed for molesting the
child actors that's nice isn't it Jesus
Christ
Jesus Christ why is it so difficult for
people to just be normal
just be normal be decent
you see a person don't molest that
person it seems like the easiest thing
in the world and yet some people seem to
find it really really difficult and I
don't understand it
um yeah granther said yeah all religions
are absurd in their own way yeah that's
kind of where I'm coming at it from
um is there such a thing as black
Mormons let's get into that a little bit
um because yeah one of the uh very
common
criticisms directed against Mormons is
the racism that's kind of like inherent
in the belief system because yeah back
in the day uh right there in the
scripture that mormonisms believe in
apparently
um yeah the darkness of your skin
equated to the evilness of your person
like basically the more holy you got
like the whiter your skin got
ah yeah they did actually really believe
that
um in 1978 they did actually uh say
because for a long time until 1978
um black people were not allowed to be
clergy in Mormonism because of that very
reason
1978 they changed that though but you
know I'm not saying it's a hell of a lot
better but
yeah so yeah John Smith said yeah black
people are not even allowed in the
clergy until the 70s I think yeah
specifically in 1978. yeah you're
talking about what the with the with the
Mormons yeah yeah for for uh for a while
they had some kind of a
a little
sag that had to be what is that white
and delightful something like that
Delight some Delight white and Delight
some yeah yeah that was a little thing
that they later they changed it to pure
and delightsome because they were like
oh well yeah they didn't want it to be
like a little bit too
well they did equate
dark skin with evil
it was like Mark of cane type stuff yeah
that's expensive that's essentially what
it is
Tom Sykes says uh that you should wear
the white wig who you no I ain't wearing
a white wig
not that drunk yet how far along have we
gotten into the material they haven't
even scratched the surface ever no I
haven't started okay I mean we've been
talking about it the whole time so
there's just kind of like stuff okay
you know what I mean so um so as I
mentioned before yeah Mormons do
actually consider themselves Christians
but uh the feeling is not mutual I guess
like a lot of Christians don't really
recognize Mormons as an official
denomination even though like I said
from my point of view it seems pretty
similar however Mormons do actually
believe that Jesus was crucified
resurrected and that he's a Divine being
but the thing about it is that Mormons
go like a step farther and say yeah
there were more prophets after Jesus
died
and that you know they're like why it's
not weird to think that like the church
has been
restored in modern times like somebody
updated the [ __ ] basically is what
they're saying
so the four books that they
follow these are kind of like their
sacred texts obviously it's just the
regular ass Bible Book of Mormon uh the
Doctrine and Covenants again uh Joseph
Smith wrote that and the pearl of great
price that's another one that he wrote
so those four books are kind of like
their main things now according to the
church Adam and Eve lived in Missouri
yeah yeah of course that's where the
Garden of Eden was after being driven
well no after they were driven out of
the garden yeah
so yeah they were in Missouri back when
the land bridge was still there I guess
I don't know I don't really know so uh
they also believe that there are three
levels of Heaven your Celestial level
that's the highest one that's the place
where God hangs out yeah and then
there's one called terrestrial and then
there's one called telesteel teles deal
so only the ones like in the celestial
one that's like the top tier that's like
the penthouse apartment right
um that's those are the people that will
just be in God's presence right yeah
now an interesting thing here's one
place where Mormonism and maybe more
mainstream Christianity differ is that
Mormons don't recognize the Trinity as
in God existing in three persons you
know God Jesus Holy Ghost whatever the
[ __ ]
they actually think that father-son Holy
Ghost are three separate beings
right which like I said to me that's
like
six of one half a dozen of another yeah
but that's apparently like a big deal
yeah the three God trick was always kind
of a
mystifying to me until I until I had it
explained later just
where they came up with this
if you have God sitting on a throne it's
plainly says that he sits upon a throne
because Jesus says at his right hand and
then the other sons of God are at you
know on the other hand I guess which are
you know the the
Jesus's brothers and sisters and you're
like hold on what are you talking about
uh you go back to the Old Testament and
and it that's the Patriot paints it's
what is it uh Yahweh chose Israel I
don't want to go into this big old thing
but it was a Pantheon it started as a
Pantheon
okay uh
so
so that's what they're talking about
what was the uh what were you talking
about now I kind of lost track the
Trinity the Trinity that's right Ben
says
yeah if there's somebody sitting on a
throne then who parted the Red Sea well
that was uh the hand of God right well
did he come off that Throne to do that
could he be in two places at once and
said yeah yeah that was God [ __ ] that
was the Holy Spirit that was God's power
on the Earth
okay so this allows God to be in more
places at once if if a miracle happens
if the burning bush talks to you
that's not God sitting on the throne
that's his holy spirit that's his hand
on the earth that you're seeing
and then when you deal with Jesus and
the words of Jesus he says that's his
son so that's that that's all it is
there isn't three of them
I had to explain this to guys you know
when I was in the Middle East to explain
this to Muslims
it says this is where they're getting
this three
because they're saying well Chris you
know Christians believe that there's
three Gods they're like no
no and then there's the Father the Son
and it's no it's not three Gods but
they're all one yes it's not three Gods
but see Mormons don't believe that right
they believe that it's three different
yeah they believe it's three different
gods right which to me makes more sense
because that other thing it's like oh
it's three people but it's one person
I'm like whatever you don't know what
you're talking about when I was in there
and dahob drunk [ __ ] explained it to
Muslims that it's no they're saying it's
the Holy Trinity is the three
manifestations that you will see of
God's power they're like yeah that's
still something they're like what and
that's just well you know what I mean
I'm parting the Red Sea it happened
right you go yeah okay that happens well
that's not God sitting on the throne
that's just his hand that's what they're
talking about and they're like oh okay
so it's all the same God yeah it's all
the same because just one there's just
one God in Christianity Jesus is not God
it's the son of God
but like I said Mormons think that all
three of them are different our other
son holy ghosts are three different
three different entities entities yeah
not like one entity you know right so
that's kind of a big I feel I feel like
that's a big point of contention yeah
between them and the Christians among
other things but I think that's one of
the main ones is the Trinity thing
but um the Trinity was an invention it's
not in the Bible Well it's all an
invention that's all I'm saying which
like to me it just seems very funny that
they're arguing about these like stupid
little yeah that's that's the Catholic
Church the Catholic Church came up with
the Holy Trinity based upon their
interpretation of the scripture
is that you're going to see God
manifested in three things
him up in heaven Miracles happening and
then
Jesus's words that's all it means there
isn't three
Jasper said how far have the LDS come
they went from A persecuted minority to
running one of their own as president of
the USA not too shabby yeah I mean they
really did come a long way because they
did I'm not gonna lie they did actually
get persecuted they got [ __ ] now they
did their own persecuting too I'm not
saying that there wasn't [ __ ] on both
sides yeah but um
they're not losers they were successful
most religions [ __ ] are gone 40 years
later
well like I said I kind of feel like I I
feel like maybe a lot of people tried to
do this [ __ ] yeah well especially
like
we talk about scientology yeah
um you know there was a lot of that kind
of [ __ ] floating around around that time
period and most of it didn't last that
long yeah most of it is not still around
today most of it was just kind of like
just you know a footnote of History yeah
but you had to kind of have all of these
right things had to go right but you
know what I mean it's just happened to
be that this you know there was a lot of
this [ __ ] going around because when
Mormonism uh was born this was what they
called uh the Great Awakening right it
was just kind of like another big kind
of like the 60s was actually but it was
kind of like this whole big
reinvigor reinvigoration of like
religious belief and spiritualism and
kind of other things where people were
searching for meaning in their lives and
stuff and it was kind of like a big deal
so I kind of felt feel like this just
happened for whatever reason to appeal
to more people than the other [ __ ]
around and most of the other stuff was
forgotten about but this one just stuck
for some reason Dr Robert Price who's
been a guest on the show in her early
days he's a great teacher you can find
his work on YouTube Dr Robert M price
Bible geek okay he knows all these
religions and he gotta Abraham religion
he's read it all right some of it [ __ ]
in the original Greek text okay
he said if you look in a lot in a lot of
a lot of the Roman stuff too said if if
you look based on his studies he says if
you look
all going all the way back to the Roman
period
the average religion lasted about 40
years
if you can Outlast that 40 years you're
a pretty successful religion yeah
Mormonism is coming up on 200 years so
yeah yeah 1830 that's when that's a
successful religion
it's grown that's that's rare most
religions don't mean 16 million people
almost 17 million actually like around
the world that's not too bad
Scientology is coming up on that that
probably beat 40 years but Scientology
is not going to make it it's in bad
shape
it was pretty successful but it was it
was very successful it's not going to be
that successful it won't live that much
I have no idea why but it was yeah it
appealed to people for some reason I I
don't get it but okay John Smith said in
the LDS I Think Jesus and Satan are
brothers too yeah they are they are
that's another thing that maybe
Christians like uh get upset about I
think it's Jesus and Lucifer they're
Brothers right in uh Mormonism pretty
yeah I guess that's been Mormonism in
yeah yeah if you actually look at the
New Testament they're not related at all
well no but that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about Mormonism yeah
yeah
Ben says metaphysically God can't enter
or exist in our world because our world
is imperfect and it would dilute him or
destroy us
yeah you know I mean like I said a lot
of the stuff is like real convenient
John Smith says much like in Hinduism
all of the many many gods are just
manifestations of the one God despite
having their own personalities
murder Hornet says I can do multiple
wives LOL
would you really want like I guess some
dudes would I don't know
I can't really I can't really relate
it's like dude
I wouldn't want multiple husbands [ __ ]
man
one dude like I said one dude is enough
to put up with if you look at Islam more
than one just makes me tired thinking
about it in Islam they could have three
but really all it is is it's
the Ex-Wives and the new wife
it's just that they don't divorce the
ex-wife the ex-wife still lives in her
own house and she's being taken care of
that that's all it is it's just we're
looking at it through a western lens
the ex-wife
usually she's older she doesn't care
what the husband's doing she's kind of
retired you know instead of her being
kicked out to the wolves and trying to
make it on her own she's got her own
house she's just retired she got her own
kids and everything
she's been I wouldn't say
replaced but she's been her duties
have been taken off of her she didn't
want to screw that dude anymore anyway
they've been married [ __ ] 20 30 years
she's sick of that dude so
there's a younger one handling her
[ __ ] wet work you know
most women don't want to [ __ ] you if you
after you've been out with them for 15
20 years anyway they're sick of you
well I mean well that's been there done
next well no I mean the thing about it
is that don't be that way Tom okay okay
but like um well the thing about what
well and particularly the thing that we
watched last night
was
those girls like a lot of them were
teenagers they didn't really have any
choice in the matter you know that's an
abuse of the system though yeah that's
that's an abuse of of nature if you ask
me in Islam according to Saad who's my
friend you know and [ __ ] like I said
that my family has Middle Eastern roots
in certain ways you know my mother's
sisters half of them are in Dubai their
husbands sick work insecurity and being
helicopter Pilots for [ __ ] Rich
Middle Eastern guys
most of the [ __ ] they do the [ __ ] that
they're doing is is basically age
appropriate it's a 50 year old guy the
second wife's in his 30s or late 20s you
know what I mean and they're they got a
lot of money those girls are happy to be
in this relationship with this dude
you know they get laid out
you know they're providers
Christian Brown says an Ancient Order of
Dagon yeah yeah I mean might as well
that seems like a more fun religion
but uh yeah so they also have I I'm
looking at this through a weird culture
here's the thing Jenny Jenny's getting
kind of judgmental over this because I'm
not an Abraham type [ __ ] but we got all
kinds of Club friends that [ __ ] are
in constant threesomes and couples that
have girlfriends and it's it's it's
wild no I'm not judgmental about it I'm
just saying that it's like I kind of
feel like the problem
The Horizon you're using those weird
scriptures these people are too young
that's what I'm saying right I don't
have a problem with everybody being
adults and like having whatever
situation you want to have a situation
and so like I don't have a problem with
that usually that's what's happening
yeah that's what I'm saying that's
absolutely fine yeah well and I think
what I was gonna say and I think we got
sidetracked and I forgot about it
but
they were talking about
um you know the early Mormons which we
will eventually get to like if we
actually get into the timeline of like
the history of the [ __ ]
um one of the reasons why they were
persecuted was specifically because of
the polygamy which was illegal and
obviously polygamy is still illegal and
I'm kind of like
I'm not sure that it should be I don't
think I think it should it should be
constitutional
I mean honestly where they didn't tell
you how many people you can marry that's
what I mean and like as long as nobody's
underage as long as nobody's being like
forced into [ __ ] well
um I don't really have a problem with
that it's illegal but they don't go
after it in the United States that's
true and even back in the day like they
even said like you know even [ __ ] Abe
Lincoln and [ __ ] like that like he was
just kind of like yeah it's illegal but
uh they don't care yeah and what are
they gonna do bust up families well
these people are actually related they
all know they're all willing who cares
that's what I mean as long as you know
as long as everyone is
willing and consenting and they're of
age yeah I don't really have a problem
with it yeah you know what I mean it's
just kind of like whatever man it's just
we just do it a different way here
traditionally With Our Generations a
dude divorces his wife his ex-wife
and he gets visitation rights on the
kids and now he's got a new wife who
tends to be about 10 to 15 years younger
now he's in a new marriage well the old
wife got kind of stuck out if you ask me
other cultures would say no no it's just
another wife you still got your
responsibility to the first wife too
here they do that through child support
yeah which what the why just just stay
married to the first wife you know what
I mean and marry the new wife
and now you got to make sure that the
first wife is taken care of you still
have all those responsibilities too okay
now if you're not sleeping with that
wife who are you
to say she can't have a boyfriend
because she's kind of put out the past
that's what I'm saying all right I kind
of feel like the problem right the why I
have a problem when it's like a
religious justification is because a lot
of times it's a double standard like the
dude can do whatever he wants to but
like the second the woman's like okay
well I'm still married to you but we're
not sleeping together anymore but I
can't sleep with another dude and then
the guy's like yeah well that's how it
works that's what I mean that's like I
don't like that that's the whole way of
looking at it right which I don't agree
with that either if you if you're not
going to sleep with your first wife
anymore she should be free she's retired
yeah all right now she marries this new
guy
it's on him to take care of her
you know what I mean now if she has any
new children from this guy you don't you
shouldn't be supporting his children
well yes you don't do that you don't do
that for your divorced wife anyway right
you know so that's just another way of
sorting that problem out yeah I think
the problem arises like I said the
problem I have is not so much I don't
really I don't care about people that
are like in polyamorous relationships or
as long as everyone's consenting
everyone's on the same page everybody is
free to do what they want to do everyone
has gone into this knowing all of the
stuff that's going on but I think the
problem with that and a lot of people
have with Mormons and other Cults like
this is that a lot of times the women
don't
have the same agency as the dudes have
and that's a lot of times that's because
of their upbringing or the way that
they're you know the beliefs are they're
not really allowed to question it you
just have to do what we say like I said
they're not really allowed to you know
it's like dudes are allowed to have like
a whole bunch of wives but they don't
let the women have a bunch of husbands I
don't know why you'd want that but like
if you did because like I said one two
it's like more than more than enough
like I'm tired thinking about it but you
know if they wanted that they should be
allowed to have that but no of course
they're not because that's like a double
standard because I kind of feel like the
whole thing with Mormonism and any of
those kind of and this is more the
fundamentalist Cults that I'm talking
about like the fundamentalist sex of it
it's just like they're very
you know they're very patriarchal
they're very misogynistic in a way and
it's just kind of like they just treat
women like
chattel you know what I mean they're
just kind of like we just trade them for
whatever so that's what I have a problem
with I don't have a problem with
everyone being an adult and everyone
getting into a situation where it's like
oh you know we're having like this is a
dude and he has like all these women
that are a harem and it's like they all
willingly went in on that and they can
leave if they want to and you know
that's fine I don't give a [ __ ] about
that and honestly I don't even really
think
like I said I don't really know if
polygamy should be
illegal I just I just don't feel like it
should be
but there have to be
you know well just like you can't force
somebody into like a regular marriage
somebody that's underage or something
like that you shouldn't be able to do
the same thing with polygamy I don't
have a problem with people wanting to
marry more than one person I don't give
a [ __ ] about that do what you want as
long as everybody knows what's going on
and everyone's on the same page I don't
have a problem with it at all
so that was kind of one thing that I
don't say I agree with the Mormons on it
because they have different reasons for
it but I'm just saying from a from an
objective standpoint I don't really have
a problem with it but um yeah so
I was kind of I was thinking about like
the the magic underwear thing
which I'm not really entirely sure like
what the background of that was because
I kind of feel like when you say Mormons
like a lot of people think like oh the
magic underwear I don't think they all
do that stuff but it's just kind of like
that what do they call it the temple
garment or whatever that they have like
that white thing that's underneath and
it just
it just has like a hole for your
genitals right because you're not really
supposed to like
see anybody naked
so I don't know that's
it's just I don't I don't know what that
whole thing's about so I also wrote down
all of these weirder beliefs now this is
where I wrote down what I talked about
earlier which I had never heard before
and I don't know if this is true or not
I just found this on some other page but
I found something that said that Mormons
feel that Satan has control over water
as in like lakes oceans rivers that kind
of stuff and that's why like Mormons
aren't really supposed to I don't think
they're forbidden expressly but it's
like yeah like just avoid swimming or
boating or anything like that because
Satan
has like hey has a whole lot of water or
some [ __ ] like that I don't really know
but like I said that was one thing that
turned up on the on the [ __ ] also
another weird thing
is that uh and I think we alluded to
this before
is that if you are a good Mormon your
whole entire life like after you die God
will give you your own planet for you to
rule over
I don't know who lives on this planet
because I kind of feel like the whole
thing
the whole thing that's
appealing about this idea is well I want
a whole planet of like people that I can
tell what to do because I kind of feel
like the kind of person that would want
to rule a whole planet because why the
[ __ ] would I want to rule a whole planet
that sounds exhausting but it's like if
you were the kind of person that wanted
to do that you're the kind of person
that's like well I want to boss other
people around and like tell them what to
do so it's like well so who are the
people on your planet then like did are
these people that are being punished and
they're getting put on your planet and
you're just like bossing them around
your entire life like you get to be your
own God on your own Planet I don't know
like it sounds cool but I don't know I
have a lot of questions
I have a lot of questions
um and so yeah another thing that we
brought up earlier was the whole
um
Kane cursed with dark skin thing
now this is in one of Joseph Smith's
books
and this is a direct quote Kane was
cursed with a dark skin he became the
father of the Negroes and those spirits
who are not worthy to receive the
priesthood are born through his lineage
he became the first mortal to be cursed
as a son of perdition so essentially the
curse of Cain was dark skin they not
only applied this to black people but
they applied this to Native Americans as
well because they weren't white enough
so basically the whiter you were the
closer to God you were and they seemed
back in the old days they did seem to
genuinely believe that the more Mormon
you were like you your skin would get
whiter
and they did actually like say that they
thought you would get whiter like as you
got more holy or something
John Smith
it makes sense because it does it yeah
it does it makes sense because
the Mormons the Mormons in general
were uh Farmers okay
and uh they were into breeding cattle
and breeding animals
they thought if you bred Mormons over
certain generations and you're weeding
out things like sickness and illness
which they did
that you would get wider
yeah all right so being as white as
possible would be a sign of being a real
good Mormon that you had been
successfully bred
over generations to be that white so
you'd be more holy and more white and
more Mormon so the Payless [ __ ]
is the best right that's what they're
thinking now
in the in in the in the 30s
Germans went down there to go look at
the birth records of Mormons and
actually confirmed that they had weeded
out a lot of a lot of sicknesses and
genetic problems uh you know it was just
things like diabetes and stuff and that
was the name was in actually in the 20s
that they went down there and looked at
that
and that was later on used
by uh the men of the bent cross you know
the the Nazis uh that confirmed a lot of
their Eugenics ideas that you could
breed humans just the way you breed
animals
which they weren't sure because this is
during the time the early 1900s
they're still kind of believing in
special creation that humans weren't
animals Tammy says imagine if you were
albino yeah
yeah you'd think albanians well I mean
I'm sure they did but they probably
would have bred that out
see because albanos are legally blind so
I don't think the Mormons would have
wanted that
Larry and creature said so Goths are
actually descendants of really good
Mormons that's what I was going to say
too my pale Alaskan the problem is
there's so many Central and South
American Goths that are kind of slightly
Shady colored and Shady Brown and Dusky
Dusky looking goths
go look at Mexican Gods they're not all
as pale as my ass no man they're [ __ ]
awesome too and then they have embraced
their inner Mexican
they're down there they look like
they're getting ready getting ready to
descend down into shabulba all right
[ __ ] like Loretta Vamps on on um
on uh Instagram she's one of the best
Gods I've ever seen and just and I think
she might be from California but she
spends a lot of time in Mexico it's hard
to tell she that's because she's putting
photos on either side of that border I
don't know if she's Chicano or or or or
or Mexican
she's a fantastic goth
you know who I'm talking about yeah yeah
she and
she'll dress up like Santa Muerte and
all kinds all kinds of and then she'll
do like a whole cholo thing where she's
doing low rider cars and just you know
any culture can become goth you just
[ __ ] take your culture and just
[ __ ] and darken it and [ __ ] dress
up well you just embrace the [ __ ]
death that's right yeah embrace the dark
side there there are some Japanese Goths
that I've been seeing lately you know
where they're look like geishas but then
they've got
spider legs coming out of their hair and
they're just that's badass yeah and
they're just with webs on the fan and
then everything is just like it so it
can be done with any culture
and um
Central and South Americans are people
of drama they love drama and fashion you
know [ __ ] so goth fits right in they
listen all the same Bands A lot of times
this is a mercy and [ __ ]
Bauhaus and new Industrial anilas in the
German industrial and then they're
making their own music so it's
everywhere
Ben says Mormon genetic records are
second to none that is I think that is
probably their main contribution to
Human
Society in progress is that they are
very meticulous about keeping records
and they also have a website that allows
you to and actually it's kind of in some
ways it's kind of better than like
ancestry.com and stuff like that
um they have like a genealogical website
that is actually free to access and it's
really really complete I've heard that
it's I haven't really [ __ ] around with
it too much but it does seem like it's
kind of it's harder to search like it's
not real user friendly yeah but um they
do have like loads and loads and loads
of Records on there so that I think is
their main good thing that they've done
is they've had like this whole because
that's very important to them like to
keep this whole genealogical record yeah
everybody and uh Ben also mentions
because I wanted to bring this up the uh
it's the Mormons who retrospectively
baptize dead people yeah which um
not surprisingly a lot of people do have
problems with that uh they did get in
trouble uh many years ago for
retrospectively
baptizing all of the uh victims of the
Holocaust which uh a lot of people were
not super happy about uh because it
seems a little tacky seems a little
tasteless I'm trying to bless them
though
I guess I get their hearts in the right
place
Optics of it not it's not so good
um it's a cultural difference they're
trying to get dead people killed in the
Holocaust into heaven that's all it is I
mean I get that like I said their
heart's probably in the right place but
implicit in their action is that they
think that they have the authority and
they're the only ones that are right
of course and so I think that's what's
offending people of course is that
implicit it's religious idea it is just
religious thinking well we are the we
are the only people that can bestow this
upon you and everything to heaven yeah
okay that's all cool though
that's cool it's just religious thing I
mean I don't love it I don't give a [ __ ]
if they do it because I'll be dead and I
won't know anything different but it's
just it's just kind of like I mean it
just seems I don't know it just seems
really tacky too yeah to be pissed off
about it I think is is petty it's the
same thing as if you showed up down at
Africa somewhere in some African tribe
[ __ ] blessed you and said you will
now go to our Heaven that's how much we
like that's the same thing
you're just getting you're just they're
just giving people the uh I mean I don't
get offended because I don't believe any
of it is true and I'm just like what
[ __ ] difference does it make yeah so
like you can say whatever you want after
I'm dead it's not gonna make a goddamn
bit of difference but I can see how
people would be offended by that because
like I said it seems a little bit those
[ __ ] are sensitive they're saying no
it seems a little bit
they're not well they're not really like
um thinking how that's gonna look it
seems to me it seems arrogant like how
they're coming at it it's just it sounds
great I'm not offended I'm not offended
either I'm just saying it sounds
arrogant when I was living in Brazil and
I go to a macumba church and the [ __ ]
priest [ __ ] blessed me and [ __ ]
thanked me for coming and said that
[ __ ] you know the spirits are gonna
[ __ ] dig you and [ __ ] like that I'm
not offended like we'll see but that's
not offensive though but that's see
that's cool I'm just saying that if I
was Jewish and I had like a relative
that had been killed in the camps yeah
and then like some Mormon came to me and
said oh well I know better and we just
like bless you and like retroactively
like baptize your relative who you
didn't even know I'm like I think I
don't think I'd be so mad that I'd punch
that person but I'm like that's a little
bit
okay it's just a cultural difference
they're trying to give those people a
gift they're saying I'm gonna we're
gonna get these people into heaven I get
that but like I said I I kind of feel
like they don't but you see they don't
seem to realize how it comes off though
because like I said it comes off as a
little bit arrogant it comes off as a
little bit arrogant of course but that
all religions are like that all
religions claim to have the secrets to
God yeah we know everything they're all
like that yeah all that that's why I
don't know that's what I hang with them
I don't like that they just stepped in
and said y'all are Jews you have not
accepted Jesus as the Savior we don't
care though we get we're going to get
you into heaven that's that's what
they're doing well yeah but like I said
that seems a little bit
condescending it seems condescending I
don't worry about it another imagination
and I don't well yeah this is all
[ __ ] voodoo doctor stuff well yeah I
think that yeah but if you actually
believe in it then yeah I can see how
you'd be offended because that is very
condescending I don't believe any of
that [ __ ] I don't either but I'm just
saying most of those Jews are probably
secular that got killed they don't
believe in any of this [ __ ] either
well like I said it's not those weren't
Orthodox like I said I'm sure like the
dead people don't care because they're
no they don't give [ __ ] I'm just
saying I can say how I can see how maybe
they're uh you know their surviving
relatives would be offended I'm like I
don't know if I'd be so like I said I
wouldn't be super offended but I'd just
be like bro
let's let's step back off that a lot I
just understand how people are just keep
your goddamn mouth I'm not offended
because I understand how dumb people are
though they just do that silly [ __ ] you
know I just think thank you thank you
thank you I'm going away but the thing
about it though is that they kind of
wish this is why the human race will
always be a disappointment to me I
always just kind of wish that people
would
shut up just you don't have to say
anything
like because I feel like a lot of times
people just like say [ __ ] and I'm just
like you know you could have just not
said that that is not the function of a
religion that is not the function of a
religion you could have just not said
that and then you wouldn't be in trouble
right now the function of a religion is
so easy is to monopol monopolize the
universal world view you know what I'm
talking about they're the ones that each
religion exists
it exists to have authority oh no no no
no we're gonna have okay no we're gonna
do commercials because we'll never get
to commercials we will never get to
commercials
no I'm done now I'm done we're gonna do
some commercials people
okay see she doesn't like she just
[Music]
[Music]
where is that raccoon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you have any body
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
good
foreign
yeah I know I saw that so the music from
the commercials [ __ ] scaring the cat
away I'm sorry I'm sorry Kitty I would
never want to scare somebody's kidding
that's terrible okay we got a lot of
material to cover and we've been [ __ ]
around like I said we don't I mean we
have been talking about Mormons this
whole time like we have covered some
[ __ ] true but you know what I mean so
it's not like we're completely randomly
talking about like a bunch of [ __ ]
but you know
um yeah so one okay so there's another
thing where the Mormons uh differ from
mainstream Christians I guess Mormons
actually believe that God was like a
dude just like a human being yeah and he
actually had actual sex with a Virgin
Mary and got her pregnant with the with
Jesus yeah which okay yeah that's what
it says
I mean pretty much yeah that's not that
weird no that's like Zeus having sex
with people together that's what I
thought to get what I have to give birth
to like Hercules and [ __ ] yeah same
thing because like I said that kind of
tracks with their whole like well God
Jesus you know Holy Spirit they're all
like three different yeah peeps that's
like you know what I mean so they're
trying to transform into a bull to have
sex with women to give birth to children
I think that's some [ __ ]
just walking down the street in like a
sexy bowl like walks up yeah I was like
Hey women can't resist it man [ __ ]
they're like you're a bowl
I don't think so yeah go find a lady
Bowl yeah but yeah so it was just kind
of like that uh also the Mormons believe
that God lives on a planet called
lobe something
yeah k-o-l-o-b okay so this was the
first uh planet that God created
evidently and um I guess I don't know if
like the planet there's like the planet
and then there's the Celestial Kingdom
but they're two different things I don't
know this is very complicated this
theology thing
so apparently on this planet a day is
equal to a thousand years on Earth
and it's the center of the universe
also Earth used to orbit
kolob this planet which was where the
gods were it's kind of like a FL like a
whole planetary like Mount Olympus
that's like out of the [ __ ] Star Trek
movies
Kirk goes to the [ __ ] planet that's
at the center of the damn Galaxy and God
is living there but it turns out to be a
false god what was the name of that the
New Frontier that's the discovery
country yeah maybe that's where they got
the idea yeah they're like hey maybe
they got it for more minutes it didn't
occur to me but I was just kind of like
oh yeah maybe maybe I mean that's it's
not that weird to think about like the
idea but it's like you can see where I
got the idea of him so apparently when
Adam and Eve fell
uh God angered the you know he got mad
like at the whole thing and kicked them
out of kicked the Earth out of the out
of its orbit you know what I mean like
we're not but the thing about it is that
I saw another documentary about
Mormonism and they said that some I
don't know if all Mormons believe this
but some sects of Mormons believe that
you know the whole like Eve eating from
the Tree of knowledge and like and all
that and it's like in Christianity
that's like really bad
in Mormonism that's kind of like good
because if she hadn't done that then
humans wouldn't have like progressed and
they wouldn't have had like children and
stuff like that so they kind of see that
as a good thing but I don't know if
that's widespread or not well Adam was
made as the gardener to God's Garden
right all right and uh Gaba walk around
there in the heat of this of the day all
right and uh uh Adam was just there to
cut the [ __ ] trees all right and then
just cut myself and he named all the
animals and [ __ ] and then God says I'm
going to make you a woman something's a
helper all right
and then Hera or the [ __ ] serpent
they're talking they're talking about
Ashura all right she's the one that
freedom basically by giving them
knowledge the same knowledge that the
gods had and then God says oh [ __ ] this
and you can't be my servant anymore [ __ ]
out of here because you know you're
gonna have to take care of yourself that
[ __ ] ruined it yeah no well it's it's
then now man becomes an he has agency
now so yeah they're there that's that's
a correct interpretation of the story
is that without that there would have
been no agency humans would have been
servants in the garden forever
see that's kind of how yeah that's kind
of how I read it I was like like I said
I'm not saying I believe in Mormonism
because I don't I'm just saying that I
can see how their interpretations their
interpretation is kind of more in line
with it's like yeah that makes sense
it's a lot more humorist because yeah
because uh that's because yeah and he
gets onion you know now no death so
you're no longer Immortal okay and then
you now you have to be fruitful multiply
so yeah no no the Mormons got that right
that's that's what this story meant yeah
yeah
so you know probably Joseph Smith's
doing yeah
in some ways it makes more sense yeah he
understood mythology it's very much like
this which is great similar to the story
Prometheus in a way
yeah yeah well like I said it's not like
he just pulled it out of his ass it's
like there were other I'm sure he was
fairly well read I'm sure that like you
know what I mean people knew this stuff
in the in the Zeitgeist back then so I
kind of feel like you're just pulling
from other stories because he was just
pulling stuff from
I mean Book of Mormon is mostly like the
Bible but yeah just remember people
other things
mankind is only mankind if you if you if
you're into this Mythos
all it says is is that mankind is
mankind because of the Fall
If the fall had never happened
you wouldn't wouldn't have existed Adam
would still just be the gardener in the
garden
along with his little helper Eve there'd
have been no mankind
because they were already immortal
which and I think that that was
something that was kind of going around
in maybe Enlightenment circles and stuff
like that because they're kind of like
well
you know if if that came along then
maybe like Lucifer the snake in the
garden and stuff like that well that's
not he wouldn't be a bad guy then
because right no the serpent was man's
benefactor that's what I'm saying he was
trying to elevate well that's I think I
feel like that was the whole offshoot
like I said from the enlightenment like
the whole Romantics movement I mean
that's kind of where they were coming
from contrary to what a lot of
Christians believe though is that the
serpent was not Satan it never says that
the Jewish father of the Gods it was his
wife so were you talking about Hera okay
Zeus and Hera all right Zeus's Garden
he's got a gardener Hera comes in and
goes you can't leave them like that here
to have some knowledge and then Zeus
goes oh [ __ ] you can't be my slave
anymore you have knowledge and then they
say he's like us now he can see like us
okay my best wife out of here yeah
[ __ ] out of here you got to take care of
yourself and uh uh no more tree of life
for you and immortality you're gonna
have to [ __ ] work the soil and be
fruitful and multiply because you're
gonna die if you don't have children
okay that that's what they're talking
about yeah
well like I said it's always been like
an excuse as to why people
get old and die yeah
they were like people are not immortal
like the gods right like they're looking
for an explanation for that that will
yeah you're a God's servant originally
and you're supposed to be immortal
feeding off the tree of life
but you don't have access to that
anymore you got kicked out of the garden
so now you have to multiply
would you really want to live forever
Just Like trimming Hedges your whole
life though yeah In the Heat of the day
that's what I mean so God could walk
around in his garden like a potentate
like a middle eastern I don't like that
idea yeah yeah especially like I was
like nah I'd rather die thanks you're
talking about the Hanging Gardens of
Babylon if you ask me that's what I
think they're talking about they
probably are yeah hanging gardens
because a lot of that stuff did have
like real world counterparts because
that's how they like imagine the stuff
they would just like idealize it yeah
but I don't know that's why I find that
kind of stuff fascinating because if you
were a middle eastern potentate one of
the most badass things you could ever
own was a garden
it wasn't video games or the [ __ ]
well because it's like I'm rich enough
that I can afford to just have this here
and I don't even need to grow food in it
I don't need I can just have it just to
look at it yeah and I walk around in
this [ __ ] when it gets hot I just walk
around in my garden
and like look at that poor schmuck over
there that has to trim all the edges
yeah and these [ __ ] hang above y'all
I'm looking down in my garden looking
down on y'all yeah I thought I could
they knew that they were talking about
well that's something we don't have the
context
well yeah but I mean humans are still
the same like a lot of humans do kind of
like do yeah they want something that
they can like look down on people it's
kind of like God's Chariot and [ __ ]
[ __ ] what they're talking about is
they're talking about the most badass
ride you ever [ __ ] this is better
than any Lambo it's better than any
[ __ ] Bugatti okay it's got [ __ ]
Wheels within wheels and [ __ ] Angels
making the wheels go go and [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's fast even when it's not moving you
know it's all that kind of [ __ ] that's
what I'm talking about yeah they're just
I mean they're just taking what I guess
like what rich people had back then and
they're just like manipulating it like
magnifying it yeah that's just which you
know people still do that nowadays
because you can only imagine so much
yeah you just take something that you
know and then you yeah idealize it you
make it bigger so I kind of feel like
that's the same thing they were doing
um also Mormons believe but you know and
like I said generally Mormons believe
that uh you know the the whole marriage
thing to however many wives you have
uh that [ __ ] holds even after you're
dead yeah because you're still
considered married in heaven so if the
marriages are polygamous which some of
them are like I said the mainstream uh
you know Mormons don't do that anymore
but you know some sects still do
um all the women in heaven still have to
share the husband yeah and uh apparently
still have to do all the housework and
apparently they still have to like have
Spirit children and they still have a
gestation period of nine months so
you're back to the Old Testament I don't
see how it's like heaven for women then
they're like oh so the same [ __ ] we had
to do on Earth no thanks
[Laughter]
no thanks you just become the heavenly
mother you become
a Hera it just doesn't sound like that
much fun to me I'm sorry yeah well the
lights are gendered maybe that's kind of
why well I think that's why religions
never appeal to me I'm just kind of like
well obviously this was written by a
bunch of old white perverted dudes so
it's just kind of like I don't want any
part of it I don't want any part of it
it doesn't sound like any fun for me it
doesn't sound yes Above So Below that's
what they're doing what it does just
like it is here it's just up there
that's what they're talking about
is that the way it is no well no I know
I've had near-death experiences and out
of body experiences [ __ ] near-death
experience during my [ __ ] motorcycle
accident I was in a coma no the
afterlife is not like that I've seen it
I believe in all that [ __ ]
what they're talking about might be
slightly based on it but the Eastern
stuff is closer
that sounds a lot cooler when you're
dying you're not even really you anymore
the you of this planet the unit of this
life you knew was just a role you were
playing
you're a lot more more child that
childlike and simpler like a little
spiritual squirrel okay you're just a
point of view yeah I like that and then
it's all these different roles you could
play and you can reincarnate and
reinhabit things or you can go into the
pleuroma and disappear for a while I
guess just a big white ball of welding
Arc of singing and but it's like an
ocean of soul
and if you go in there you're not coming
back at least not in this life
but uh that's based on whatever but I
mean think how much nicer that idea is
it's like yeah you're just gonna go and
be
um absorbed into the soul sea yeah like
just everybody and you're just like one
with everybody that sounds a lot cooler
to me than hey you're gonna die and also
have to like service this [ __ ]
yeah no you in the afterlife and also
have babies and also like you know it's
like it's very much like the Eastern
stuff uh and even the east western stuff
which would be kind of like manichaeism
manichaeism which is a mixture of
Buddhism with Islam and Christianity
that's kind of what Star Wars was about
there is a religion that was like that
that existed for a long time
manichaeanism okay
I would say I would say that I was a
manichaean which is kind of like
something out of Star Wars
when you die you become one with the
force
you can come back though
but not in this life in another life
that'd be a good way to describe it
everything I love with Star Wars and
Star Wars games and reading Eastern
Buddhist philosophy martial arts out of
body experiences all that kind of [ __ ]
all that
that's really what closer to what it's
like anything's possible including
psychokinesis or recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis seeing ghosts seeing the
past seeing dead people
um getting messages from dead people
that that's all a possibility some of it
I've I've actually had happen to me
um
and then you say well what does science
say about that
go look at Stuart hammeroff and [ __ ]
the quantum Soul Theory Quantum you know
quantum physics will eventually explain
it
it's just weird [ __ ] man [ __ ] reality
is weirder than you think it is
like I said I'm way more down for that
than some of this [ __ ] yeah
I don't want more of the same no it's
not more of the same that's what I mean
it's just like it just seems like to me
the religions that say that it's like oh
it's like this but it's this is a bigger
version it's bigger with more lights and
harps and yeah no thanks no thanks it's
totally different sound of that it's the
spiritual internet I don't like the
sound of that see that sounds a lot
cooler yeah that sounds a lot cooler
like you can kind of be absorbed into
the whole life yeah like I like that I
like that you could live in a metaverse
that's responsible yeah yeah see that's
way cool and then you're also you're an
evil person who's bad so you'll be in a
in a place that's bad and you kind of
bird off your impurities for a while and
you come back
the zoroastrians believed in that
yeah so they're heavens and Hells
and then there are things outside of
that
yeah oh he's talking about
Zoroastrianism yeah he said Ben said I
think he means oroastrianism manichaeism
was from the 4th Century 80. yeah yeah I
know I've talked about it both I know I
know what the man who the mannequins are
in the zoroastrians are yeah but no I'm
more like a more like a
more like a mannequin which we're closer
to kind of like the Jedi in his and the
Sith they were like that
so let's do a little bit let's talk a
little bit about the history of
Mormonism like all the stuff that
happened back in the day
so according to Mormon scripture
sometime around 600 BCE
there was an Israelite named Lehigh
and he goes him and his family they go
to the Middle East uh from the Middle
East to the Americas
already you're being like wait what yeah
they went to the Americas in 600 BC
um so yeah so they do that now Lehigh's
descendants end up dividing into two
tribes
the Nephites or the Nephites uh and the
lamanites who are named after two of
Lehigh's sons who were Nephi and
limp lemon lemon whatever his name was
laminate I don't know what his name was
um so the Nephites who were
kind of the more religious and like
better people I guess they actually end
up becoming corrupt over time and start
fighting with the lamanites now the
lamanites are actually considered the
ancestors of the Native Americans
because if you don't know Mormons
actually do believe that
um
well they believe that Jesus later came
to the United States essentially or what
became the United States and
was there with the Native Americans it
was a whole thing it was a whole thing
yeah
so yeah so these two are like fighting
33 A.D obviously uh Jesus gets crucified
but also around this time he appears in
the Americas and preaches to the
Nephites this other tribe that was in
the United States
um and because he showed up this brings
in a period of harmony with the
lamanites that last 200 years but
inevitably the two of them like start
fighting again
now in 385 A.D there's a nephite prophet
named Mormon hence why the thing is
called Mormons
and he's been doing like a history of
his people
now right before there was like some big
battle with the other tribe the
lamanites Mormon uh turns over he's
written all the [ __ ] down and this will
become apparently the basis for the Book
of Mormon uh which he has transcribed
into gold plates you know which we'll
get into a little bit he gives that to
his son whose name is Moroni or Moroni
like I said I've heard it pronounced
both ways
now Mormon actually is in this battle
and he gets mortally wounded
at a place called kumora
and the Nephites almost get wiped out
but Moroni survives another 36 years and
he starts adding material to this book
that his dad wrote the Book of Mormon
and then he seals the plates up in in
421 A.D hold on Ben I'm not talking
about the historical Jedi I'm talking
about the Hollywood Jedi from Star Wars
they're from the 70s that's [ __ ]
Joseph Campbell all right
so don't mistake what I'm talking about
when I say Jedi I'm talking about Star
Wars Jetta
it's good Ben says Jesus also toured
Tibet through to Japan apparently he's
buried in a tomb in Japan also in Korea
everybody wants to claim Jesus you know
a lot of the religions a lot of the
religions [ __ ] um ancient religions
spread over areas that people don't
realize where they were there was
Christianity in Japan and Korea going
back a long time 1400 1500s okay
it was it kind of faltered but then it
kind of came back and
um
the mannequins when they were around
there were there was Islamic and
Christian versions of the mannequins but
then they ended up being in China
but it was kind of like an add-on kind
of like a you could be a Christian and a
mannequin kind of like you could be a
Christian and you could be a Mason just
like that you know
Tom thanks is asking a bunch of
questions about Mormons and by the way
James Bond was a mannequin I'll call him
again
are Mormons allowed to give their wives
a facial
I mean I would imagine probably no but
you never know some of the sex maybe
they're okay with it
Larry and creature Jesus World Tour
missed it I did as well I did as well
uh but yeah
so the plates are sealed up and
apparently like buried in the ground
somewhere since 421 A.D
1805 little Mr Joseph Smith is born a
couple days before Christmas of 1805 in
Vermont
now his parents I guess like are farmers
not real uh prosperous I guess
so one thing that is going to factor a
lot into Joseph Smith's life later on is
that they do like a lot of treasure
hunting and as I said around this time
period there was a lot of stuff about
occult and spiritualism stuff was kind
of on the rise so one thing that his dad
would do
was that he would use kind of like
divination tools like stones and things
like that that supposedly
showed you where treasure was
basically they're just like they would
just have they just look like regular
rocks but they would call them like sear
stones and it's like hey if I go out
there it's okay you know what I mean
it's kind of like a [ __ ] paranormal
type thing where it's like well we're
gonna go out in this place and like use
these Seer stones and the Seer stone is
gonna tell us where the treasure is
spoiler alert they never did find any
treasure but you know they really did
believe in it apparently
um and one of the things that they would
do too and this also factored into uh
The Book of Mormon [ __ ] later on was
that they would take the Seer Stone and
for whatever reason I don't know what
the origin of this was but they would
put it in like a hat like they would
turn a hat upside down and like put the
rock in the bottom and then you'd like
look in the Hat and somehow like The
Rock was supposed to show you [ __ ] I
guess like you're supposed to have some
kind of like special [ __ ]
psychic vision from looking at a rock in
a hat which
I don't know man this [ __ ] sounds
ridiculous but yeah
that's what they were doing back in the
1800s they didn't have anything better
to do apparently
so looking at rocks and hats thinking
that that was gonna like make them find
some treasure
that's just what you did
so uh so yeah so they do that a few uh
years now the Smith family as I said
Farmers but not real prosperous they end
up moving to New Hampshire
um and their financial situation gets a
little bit better so the kids actually
like do go to school for a few years
however uh five years after that in 1816
um you know the crops have failed for
three straight years actually a fun fact
1816 was yeah the year without a summer
because that was after the uh that
volcano Krakatoa it was no it wasn't
cracking toe it was um [ __ ] I can't
remember the name of the volcano but the
volcano went off it was like it was the
same uh summer that you know uh Mary
Shelley and all them were at the Villa
Dio Dancy like I said that's why I was
remembering that volcano went off and it
basically made really really bad Winters
for several several years and like the
crop side and like all kind of like bad
[ __ ] happened because of that stuff but
yeah so they had had three years of crop
failures so they ended up moving to
Palmyra New York
now uh at the time only 4 000 people
lived here Palmyra New York I feel like
was kind of like I don't know if I call
it the epicenter but it was kind of like
a main Hub of
these new religious uh groups you know
what I mean because like I said this was
they call this what the Second Great
Awakening or something like that because
it was like a lot of stuff going on
about like spiritualism and new
religious movements and it was kind of a
big thing and I kind of feel like
Palmyra
in this area was where a lot of new uh
religious movements got their start like
it seemed to be like I don't know just a
hub of that kind of stuff like a lot of
evangelist type [ __ ] going on
1817 uh Brigham Young actually he's
gonna Factor the story later on but he
um his family is in New York and he kind
of like sets on his own to be a
carpenter or something like that and he
will meet up with them at some point
later now in 1820 Joseph Smith who is 14
years old
he's been kind of like interested in
religion but he doesn't really know
which one to
follow like he's kind of like well they
all seem
you know I don't really know which one's
the right one you know what I mean so
he's getting kind of like stressed out
about it
now Apparently one morning he goes out
into the woods
and he sees a vision
this vision is a pillar of Light which
comes from heaven
and he sees an image of God and Jesus
who were two separate dudes just two
dudes like standing in front of him like
all Celestial and whatnot
and they're like hey we forgive all your
sins
um and also all the denominations the
Christian denominations all that shit's
wrong yes
it means that we're gonna reboot all
this right
that's it yeah that that's what
basically what they said
so he's like don't join any of that [ __ ]
because they're all wrong
now um the Mormons it you know nowadays
call this the first vision
now even though Joseph Smith apparently
like I don't know I guess this is a big
deal but I guess it didn't like super
change his life at the time so you know
he continues to do the same [ __ ] he was
doing before he still works on the farm
of his family still does the treasure
hunting [ __ ] with The Rock in the Hat
with his dad and all that other kind of
stuff
and he does actually like mention the
vision that he saw to a local Minister
like hey what do you think about that
and he's like whatever yeah like [ __ ]
you dude [ __ ] you dude whatever I got my
own [ __ ] going I gotta make money with
Jesus now coming here with this right
that's yeah we're like what oh God and
Jesus came to you and said all our
shit's wrong yeah yeah right it was It
was kind of he was trying to recruit him
probably that's yeah that's what I'm
saying what do you think about this man
we could roll with this
well I mean he was only about 14 at this
time so I don't know if he was really
that Savvy maybe he was I don't know
but
I don't we'll see the thing about it is
that
a lot of the Mormon beliefs come from
Joseph Smith and come from like what he
said
so do we really know that this should
happen when he's 14 or is this something
that he wrote later on you know what I'm
saying like when he was an adult and
said oh man when I was 14 because it's
not like anyone else was there like to
corroborate the story you know what I'm
saying
yes yeah
because he didn't really tell anybody
about this until like much later except
for that one guy but then like that's
all on him though that's all from his
perspective so he could just be totally
bullshitting
so uh in 1823 he apparently has another
vision
and this is the vision of the Angel
Moroni or Moroni
and he says hey
there's this book that's written on gold
plates I always kind of thought whenever
I think about it I always think like
gold plates like a [ __ ] dinner plate
but it's not like that no it's like it's
basically it's like a three-ring binder
yeah but it's like they're they're like
pages but they're like made of gold but
the thing about it is that when I've
seen artistic representations of it I
said I hope that those pages aren't made
of actual gold because that shoe would
be super heavy yeah heavier than lead
so I don't really know real thin
either that or maybe I don't know maybe
they're just gold-plated maybe they're
just gold colored
like maybe it was like goldish paper
I was like was that really like gold
metal because they need metal
yeah
but yeah so if you're thinking like it's
gold plates like I was thinking for a
long time whenever I heard that I
thought it was just squares no they're
just they're pretty like Scientology
their page did the same thing but with
titanium right you know they look like
book pages but they're made of gold like
they're you know what I mean but they're
and they're in like essentially a
three-ring binder I think he even said
there was like three rings so it's like
a three ring binder
what's what is what we would call it
nowadays
so he's like yeah there's his book and
it's written on gold plates uh and it's
buried in a hillside like not far from
here
and um it talk it tells all about these
people that used to live here
and you know so it's it's kind of like
the the ultimate truth right
so
a couple did like the next day Joseph
Smith goes and finds allegedly he goes
and finds this book in a box on kumora
which like I said was where one of the
battles took place like back in the
[ __ ] old days
now uh coincidentally
this book was found only three miles
from where uh his farm was so you know
that that was handy
but he gets told by the angel
well yeah you found him but you can't
take them yet
what you have to do is it's September
22nd like 1823. you have to come back on
every September 22nd for like the next
four years and God's got to tell you
some [ __ ] like instruct you on what you
got to do before you can have them like
you got to leave them there right
um so Joseph's like man you you're not
the boss of me and he tries and he tries
to touch the Box anyway and just like
the [ __ ] Ark of the Covenant in Rage
the Lost Ark it like it doesn't melt his
face off but it like shocks him right
and he gets like thrown to the ground
because it's like it's like I told you
not to touch that [ __ ] leave it four
years [ __ ] so there's there's
that so he can't take it right away this
is his story anyway it's a pretty good
story it's a pretty good story I don't
believe it but it's a pretty good story
1825 uh October of that year but Joseph
Smith and his dad they joined this
treasure hunting Expedition uh in
Harmony Pennsylvania which is about 130
miles from their house uh they don't
find any treasure however Joseph Smith
does meet uh and fall in love with the
woman that would eventually become his
wife Emma Hale
now the following year 1826
um this is kind of funny to me
there's actually a record of a criminal
complaint against Joseph Smith for guess
what fraudulent use of seer Stones
because remember how I was saying he put
the stones in the Hat and it's like oh
we're finding treasure apparently that
was illegal you can't use magic rocks to
find treasure
or you'll get arrested yeah it might
work that's cheap that's cheating yeah
you can't do this cheating so uh so yeah
he he got in trouble for that for using
serums yeah and he's like um yeah I used
to use those but I don't use them
anymore so you know just you know get
off my back kind of [ __ ] but it
okay what a weird thing to have a law
against they knew what they're who they
were dealing with back then I guess yeah
it's just [ __ ] like that is just very
funny to me
all right so 1827 uh you know Joseph
Smith and Emma hell get married and uh
four years have passed so Joseph's like
I'm gonna go dig up that gold plate book
that that angel was telling me about
so the angel also told them don't let
anybody else see that [ __ ] like I said
very convenient
um so he doesn't show anybody the book
at first although he does show his mom
the magic glasses
um that would let you translate they're
essentially I Googled glasses they're
good Google translate guys pretty much
well they're they look like regular
spectacles but apparently they have like
precious stones instead of glass yeah
they yeah and they're like especially
like they're they're supposed to be
magic right
yeah quite imagination that's what I'm
saying it's like this is a good story
yeah this ought to be a movie
you can make this [ __ ] into a movie well
they've made like really really bad like
lame cartoons out of it yeah yeah
they're actually spooky some of the
cartoons that I've seen
they are kind of spooky
Larry and creature said God should
really start appearing to the masses not
just one guy in the woods you know yeah
right
the masses can't be trusted with this
kind of information
well I'm special though like I'm special
so God had to like come to me yeah you
know what I mean of course
Jesus Christ
so it's a I don't know there's just like
this whole [ __ ] [ __ ] can't trust the
average public with this You Gotta Give
it to a real leader man yeah yeah
man why didn't I think of some [ __ ] like
this I thought I should have thought if
we thought of some [ __ ] like this would
be rich probably
yeah there's a bunch of people that
would believe this crap yeah even
nowadays
but uh but yeah so he shows them the
magic glasses
and uh these glasses
are supposedly going to help Joseph
Smith translate this gold book from the
language in which it was written which
was a made-up language it's called
Celestial something right reformed
Egyptian reformed Egyptian that's right
okay when they send it to an actual
egyptologist he's like this just looks
like someone doodling on a piece of
paper yeah what is this [ __ ] they
did this on purpose because yeah in that
era [ __ ] um
now this is before this is before they
found the uh Rosetta Stone
so yeah because they didn't find that
until like what 10 years later 1837
Napoleon's troops found it yeah I saw it
in London it's like it's quite cool so
they didn't have any way of translating
Egyptian text yeah so they had all these
pyramids and all these [ __ ] great
temples and they see all this
hieroglyphics on there
and uh it allowed the eight the
imagination of the 1800s to just run
wild clearly and it was this is this
goes back to what I was saying there's a
lot like spirit spiritism in the United
States of spiritualism of the United
States with you know with automatic
writing and uh psychic abilities and
yeah it was all kind of it was a new age
it was all going real new each other
yeah
so he's just saying yeah it's in a new
age writing that's what he's talking
about like the Egyptian stuff but better
it's better and I'm the only person that
can translate it because it's not a real
language that's what he's talking about
because this Angel gave me these magic
glasses yeah
then they found that Rosetta Stone
which is nothing more than a pub a
public monument that was up in Egypt for
a while that had Egyptian on one side
it's the same message over and over
again yeah it was like three different
masks before because it was a it was it
was a I thought it was four
pretty sure it was just three but was it
three okay you could be right but I
think and it was the same message
written in Egyptian
I think Latin wasn't it great Greek is
that it was I think in uh some kind of a
Sanskrit type language
and uh or what or was it uh
I don't think it was a Sanskrit form was
it no no no
um [ __ ] what was the other one I can't
remember now like I said I've seen it
but it's not big it's like not I mean
it's big but it's not just a plaque and
it doesn't really say much it's just
commemorating an area and telling
visitors yeah it's just like regular
[ __ ] and that that allowed that that
allowed them to [ __ ] to crack the uh
the hieroglyphs yeah because they knew
the other two languages yeah so it was
pretty important
but before that era
if Egyptian hieroglyphs was just magical
writing yeah you could do whatever you
wanted with it you could say oh that
that's that's a spell that [ __ ]
brings back the [ __ ]
dead you know you can say anything you
can anybody can make any kind of claims
but I will say that I admire Joseph
Smith's
hustle because even though Egyptian
hieroglyphs had not been translated at
this time he was still Savvy enough to
be like well this isn't those
hieroglyphs I'm gonna go like a
different I'm gonna go with like a
made-up language but it's kind of like
related to that so then nobody can call
me out on the ball right
well that too and they would know hey
man these glyphs don't exist anywhere on
these buildings so he says yeah these
are the new ones that's what he's
talking about yeah like I said reformed
Egyptian that's not a real no language
no
that's not a real language but um but
yeah but like I said that was pretty
smart like for scam purposes that's like
a pretty smart thing to do because it's
just kind of like well I'm the only
person that can translate these because
the angel came to me and gave me the
magic glasses so and nobody else can
like check your work so like I said
he was he was thinking ahead if if this
was indeed a scam which I kind of feel
like it was I don't know how much he
thought about this beforehand but
if he didn't you know that that was like
a pretty good thing to like think of
just doing something that nobody else
could read
now uh so yeah so he has that going on
now because he also supposedly has this
golden Bible like all of these pages
that are made of gold
um rumors of it got around nobody knows
who leaked the information or whatever
but Joseph and his wife are kind of like
well yeah we need to like get the [ __ ]
out of here because somebody's gonna
come in here and steal the [ __ ]
now they actually did get some financial
support from a farmer who was a friend
of theirs whose name was Martin Harris
and so they moved to Harmony
Pennsylvania and they hid the gold
plates in like a barrel like full of
beans and stuff so nobody would like
take it
so they go and stay with Emma's dad
and Joseph starts translating
the writing in this alleged gold book
and used in his magic glasses and he's
basically like telling his wife Emma
like what the book says so that's how
they're doing it
so the following year 1828 Martin Harris
like I said the farmer that gave him
money
um he actually went to Harmony
Pennsylvania with them
so he starts working on the book too and
he starts like writing down the
dictation which okay so he's like
looking in the [ __ ] hat or like
whatever he's doing
and then he's just like hey it says this
that and the other thing which like I
said crazy
so over the next couple months they
um they have 116 pages that they've
written
now Martin Harris at this point he takes
it back to Palmyra in New York and he's
going to show his wife because she
doesn't believe any of this [ __ ] is true
so he takes it back there and shows it
to her
and
loses it now there's a couple different
stories about this the most common story
is that the wife
reads the [ __ ] and then she picks it up
and she throws it in the fireplace and
she's like hey if this is really
divinely inspired she'll just be able to
write it again which like I said Gangsta
I was like yeah I like her that's that's
awesome because that's probably
something I would have done
I don't know if that's the true story or
not but that's like the most common
story there's a couple other common
stories too that maybe he just lost in
or I don't know where he left it on top
of the car I don't know but like that's
kind of the most common one she threw it
in the fire and she's like yeah we'll
just write it again if it was divinely
inspired look at Pokey look at Pokey
she's listening to the show you listen
to the show Pokey hahaha
she's like okay
oh my goodness
uh but yeah so they lost the [ __ ] 116
Pages all that worked down the [ __ ]
toilet
so late for that same year Emma Joseph's
wife uh she has a kid Alvin uh and the
kid dies the same day uh they had 11
kids but only five of them would survive
into uh adulthood or well actually not
even adulthood but like most of them
died when they were babies which
happened a lot back then
now at this point like Joseph is like
man I gave [ __ ] Martin that [ __ ]
book what the [ __ ] did he do with it so
he goes back to Palmyra and figure and
Martin was like I guess still there and
he's like
sorry like I [ __ ] lost it he's like
you [ __ ]
so um basically what happens Joseph goes
back and it's like to the angel
allegedly and says
um hey I gave it to my stupid friend and
he lost it and so an angel comes and
then an angel uh takes the gold plates
away for a little while it's like I'm
taking these because you can't be true
I'll give back to them later but you
know what I mean like you can't be
trusted with this [ __ ] do you know what
I mean so later on that like a couple
months later the angel apparently gives
the gold plates and the interpretation
glasses back to Joseph Smith's like here
now don't [ __ ] it up this time
so uh 1829
a school teacher named Oliver countery
he comes to Harmony Pennsylvania and he
starts doing the scribing for uh
Joseph's myth as he starts translating
the old plates again so they finish
working in June of that year
now one of the things that they do
before they're done though is him like
Joseph Smith and Oliver cowdery they go
into the woods and they say that John
the Baptist appears to them
and confers the aaronic priesthood upon
them not really sure what that is but it
sounds cool anyway priesthood of Aaron
yeah
[Laughter]
it's made up [ __ ] well yeah that's what
I mean so I'm just saying it's like yeah
it sounds cool but whatever
um basically he says okay well now you
guys
um this whole priesthood is also going
to be restored and like you're gonna
have the power to like uh give the gift
of the Holy Ghost laying on hands and
all that kind of stuff
so John the Baptist tells Joseph Smith
you're going to be the first Elder of
the church and Oliver counter will be
the second Elder and then the two dudes
like baptize each other in the river
where they have the Susquehanna River
which is where they are
so June of that year Joseph Smith
finishes the translation
and he gets a copyright for the Book of
Mormon
now 11 Witnesses later signed statements
that they have actually seen the gold
plates which I find very hard to believe
but okay
um and three of them including Harris
Martin Harris and Oliver cowdery they
say that they also saw the angel that
brought the plates again which I find
very hard to believe but okay I don't
even know if these Golden Plates even
existed did they no that's what I'm
saying no who saw them 11 people said
they saw them I was like um
did they though
no no try not I doubt it where are they
well they're all dead now no where are
the plates that's what I mean
like I said it all just sounds very it's
it's very fishy
yeah look it's the Ten Commandments were
still around all right those [ __ ]
would be in a museum
you know a Jewish Museum and they're
like these are the tank of Memphis and
they would be letting people see them
you're gonna test them all you want
that's them
but you don't see that
you know then says the angel took them
back yeah that's right that's right I
forgot that's why I don't have them
anymore Angel took him back he's like
yeah because I think I think eventually
they asked Smith to see the see him he
said no the angel took him back yeah
that's right very convenient yeah
all that [ __ ] is just like very very
convenient yeah Ben said the Ten
Commandments are still around there in
the Ark of the Covenant yeah yeah
where's that you know nobody knows where
that is that's what I mean only Indiana
Jones knows
the Nazis knew until their faces melted
off yeah but yeah
so uh so that same year so Joseph Smith
gets a publisher for the Book of Mormon
in Palmyra at New York and they start
typesetting on it so they do a 5 000 uh
copy initial print run and Martin Harris
you know one of the original translators
he actually mortgaged his farm to put up
the three thousand dollars to publish
the [ __ ] so there's that
so they published The Book of Mormon in
1830 which like I said that's kind of
considered the birth of the Mormon
church because this was when their holy
book was published each copy of the Book
of Mormon sold for 1.25 back in 1830
which sounds like a lot of money for
1830. that seems like a lot of money
probably 30 bucks yeah
now at this point
um Brigham Young Who was a Methodist at
the time he actually moved with his wife
uh to the area near Palmyra like in 1830
and he read the book of Mormon not too
long after it was published and so he
got baptized as a Mormon a couple years
later on so he apparently like got
really into this [ __ ]
so they have the first organizational
meeting of the LDS
um in April of 1830 and 50 people were
in attendance
so uh Joseph Smith and Oliver cowdery
they are the elders and Joseph Smith
will also become known as the prophet
uh so the first four Mormon missionaries
including Oliver cowdery uh they started
heading west that October so very like
if from the very beginning of the
religion they were very very focused on
missionary work they were going to go
out and like
tell people about their [ __ ] story
now in June of that same year
interestingly Joseph Smith got arrested
and charged with the charge was being a
disorderly person
which okay these disorderly I guess for
his preaching but I don't know what
exactly he was doing like preacher-wise
that would make him disorderly but yeah
they arrested him but he got acquitted
so uh in October of 1830 the
missionaries are taking the Book of
Mormon to the Indians the Native
Americans in Ohio and Missouri
and they've stopped in Kirtland Ohio
now there's a Baptist Minister there
named Sydney Rigdon and he decides he's
going to join the Mormons and bring his
congregation with them which is about a
hundred people
now soon after this uh Joseph Smith has
another vision
and this Vision says we should move this
little community that we're building to
Kirtland Ohio
so they basically uh start to do that
some of the missionaries too also go on
to Missouri and start settling in
Independence Missouri
so in February of 1831 Joseph and Emma
Smith get to Kirtland Ohio and other
church members like would
come later on
so the church is actually based here for
the next six years and while he's there
he has like a whole bunch of Revelations
there's kind of a whole bunch of other
like uh things that he adds to the [ __ ]
now after like in June of that year the
missionaries some of the missionaries
get to Missouri and they settle in
Independence like I said now at this
point Joseph Smith he takes a group of
Mormons from Kirtland Ohio West to
Independence Missouri
and then he says well God told me that
Kirtland is going to be the New
Jerusalem so we're all going there
so in August of that year they put a
Cornerstone down for a temple
and so about 800 members like of the
church because it's growing pretty
pretty fast at this point they moved to
this area and they're thinking about
building a temple there but Joseph Smith
says well for now we're going to keep it
in Kirtland Ohio but you know for
whatever
so Joseph Smith also around this time
starts working on another translation of
the Bible which he says is like inspired
by visions or whatever
now interestingly In 1832
here's something I think a lot of people
don't know about Mormons like I said I'm
not saying that it I'm not saying this
to like make you sympathize with them or
anything like that but they were
horribly horribly persecuted like back
in the old days
um In 1832
there was they had gotten so influential
in the area that Joseph Smith was
actually captured by a mob and tarred
and feathered in Kirtland Ohio
uh this happened quite a lot they got
attacked they got [ __ ] up
um you know we'll get it out later on
but people did really not like them
coming into the area you know what I
mean
so what Tom Tom Sykes is asking me about
whether the girl that I showed the
Mormon princess that I went to prom with
whether or not she was a good lay for a
Mormon
look man that was not my girlfriend
she's a friend of mine
uh we went to high school together she
was one of the prettiest girls at school
uh she was real cool
within the limits she was not allowed to
do a lot of [ __ ]
the Mormon Secret Service would come to
school and check up on her
that was some weird [ __ ] when you had
guys in their [ __ ] 20s and 30s and
[ __ ] suits and [ __ ] check up on her
and see if she was behaving herself
yeah
um kind of cramps your style a little
bit yeah her dad was [ __ ] important
so she couldn't date anybody she didn't
have a boyfriend
she was uh
she knew she was different than other
people she kind of wanted to fit in with
everybody else in some ways she did but
she was very limited about what she
could get away with and what she could
do
um
but uh no man we just had a [ __ ]
regular
clean date I didn't give a [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] I had a girlfriend at that
time and at that particular time
the thing is is I couldn't at that
particular time I was dating a Japanese
Brazilian girl named notier notier
shibutani was her name and Japan had a
huge Japanese
um Community they'd been there since
forever before Brazil had it Brazil had
a big Japanese Community before even
World War II started
it was kind of funny they were by that
time
I got there they were mostly half
Japanese half Brazilian so they didn't
really look like Japanese people they
didn't speak Japanese they were just
Brazilian people
so it's not like I had to like be
scabbing on
Mormon girls for my school or anything I
had a high girlfriend
so it didn't really matter
it was just the thing is is that you
really couldn't take girls that
that weren't in your school to this
problem
just the way it was
you had to go to prom with somebody from
your school
I didn't like rich girls you know I
liked middle class girls and she was a
middle class girl I didn't like
Brazilian rich girls especially they
were [ __ ]
problematic
problematic uh whiny crybaby pampered
okay I hated that kind of [ __ ]
no that's always okay yeah
um let me see where uh Elizabeth Jack
said I love the kitty we love the kitty
too she's like our baby girl Michael K
one Holy Catholic Apostolic Orthodox
Christian Church uh I'm a Russian
Orthodox Christian and I will not mess
with spiritual things outside of the
church I dig your channel and mindset
thank you very much that's very nice of
you yeah Russian Orthodox back on the
rise that's another big church
yeah that that Americans don't know
about but the the Russian Orthodox they
they're also kind of like they're the
[ __ ] that's the [ __ ] Catholic Church
of the East without a lot of the
[ __ ] that the Catholics were doing
and uh
the Egyptian Coptic that's another real
old church I need to do some more
research on that to find out what
they're about but they're probably a
trip too but the Russian Orthodox man
that's Dracula [ __ ] there man that's
that's the awesome [ __ ] it's a Dracula
[ __ ] that's the Dracula Christianity
so yeah Joseph Smith got tired and
feathered In 1832 is what I'm saying
so they start building a big Mormon
temple
in Kirtland Ohio at 1833 which took
three years to finish
also around this time uh Joseph Smith
published another book called The Book
of Commandments which was like his whole
thing of like Revelations
now later that year the Mormons that
were in Missouri they started getting uh
persecuted by other people because like
I said people were really not receptive
to the Mormons like moving into their
area
um the printing press on which the book
of Commandments was printed uh a mob
came in and destroyed that so you know
um and mobs basically like started
beating up on all these [ __ ] Mormons
and [ __ ] like that so they were kind of
forced out of uh Jackson County where
they were and they got sent across the
Missouri River to Clay County like
pretty late that year
um actually they were trying to like
[ __ ] up the book too like they had to
like scoop all the pages out of the mud
and [ __ ] like that so you know
at this point Brigham Young also arrives
in Kirtland
Ohio
uh later on in 1835 they published a
book called Doctrine and Covenants which
was 138 of Joseph Smith's Revelations
and um you know just that's another kind
of like big uh book in Mormonism
in 1836 uh again the Mormons that were
Missouri get run out of Clay County to
another more remote County Caldwell
County in Davies County that's where
they got moved to in the northern part
of the state because people were just
like not having it
so yeah they did that so March of that
year they have a thousand worshipers and
they're on they built they finished
their Temple and they're doing their
Temple dedication ceremonies and a bunch
of them said that a whole bunch of like
magical [ __ ] happened man it was just
like uh winds rushing through there they
saw a pillar of fire Angels were showing
up it was a whole thing it was a whole
vibe that they saw
now apparently during this dedication
ceremony there was another Visionary
experience in which Joseph Smith and
Oliver cowdery who was like the second
in command or whatever
um they went behind
I don't know the okay so they went
behind this Veil and this where the
elevated pulp Pulpit was set like
separated from the rest of the temple
right and then he
I don't know this doesn't make any sense
to me what it says is
in which the prophet has retired behind
a veil that separates an elevated Pulpit
from the rest of the temple see a
personage they believe is Jesus
accepting the temple as a place where he
will manifest himself to his people so I
guess they're kind of like Hey we're
going back here hey there's Jesus Jesus
says hey this place is cool with me or
whatever I'm kind of feeling like that's
what they're getting at like I said a
lot of this religious uh terminology
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
they also said that they saw
Moses and Elijah and Elias and they're
all there being like yeah man this is
the right thing you're doing the right
thing we're all on board for it and they
give them like
keys to Israel whatever the [ __ ] so you
know they're giving their approval I
guess so there's that they're giving the
blessing see yeah they saw all the [ __ ]
they saw all the [ __ ]
also
here's another thing and I kind of feel
like this needs a whole show unto itself
because
I was watching something about this
earlier today and I'm just kind of like
yeah this okay
so November of 1836 Joseph Smith like
starts essentially his own bank
because I guess she could do that
so he starts something it's called the
Kirtland safety Society Bank
but apparently what happened and I think
this was happening like other people
started their own Banks too I guess it
was a thing
so he starts this bank and he starts
printing his own currency
but
I guess something happened where you
know you can't just like print your own
currency currency and like just pull it
out your ass because you don't like if
you don't have anything to back it up
and people start hearing about that then
be like oh [ __ ] this isn't worth
anything and then it's gonna like blow
up in your face and I think that's like
essentially what happened like for a
while like he printed the notes that
said you know that have the fancy thing
about like the bank and everything but
then he had to like reprint them and it
said like anti-bank because there was
like a whole anti-bank movement which
like I said that should be like another
whole show unto itself
but yeah so there was an economic
collapse started happening about
spring of 1837 and that actually led to
his bank collapsing and so it was like
this whole thing but it was just kind of
like I don't know like I was reading all
this stuff about myself like what
anti-bank movement what the [ __ ] is that
so it's because I never heard of that
before so it's like yeah like they were
even printing their own [ __ ] currency
it's crazy it's crazy so it was like you
could just do anything back then it was
just like wow well because where they
were
I mean they were kind of still out I
don't want to say it was like the
frontier Frontier because it was still a
state but it's just kind of like there
really wasn't any
it's not like we would think about
nowadays you could just basically do
what you wanted which is very very
I don't know just kind of like you could
do whatever you wanted
so um 1837
um actually the Mormons started going
overseas and started like trying to pick
up converts in England and stuff as well
now in 1838 uh Smith actually gets out
of Kirtland Ohio and starts heading
toward Missouri and he gets there with
his family in March of that year yeah
right what are you eating
well don't I'm trying to talk don't give
me that
don't ask for it I didn't ask for it I
said what are you eating
yeah that wasn't asking for it I was
just asking you what you were eating
because your mouth was full I didn't ask
you for any
Ben says uh Banks were issuing currency
based on their holding physical gold and
silver there was no regulation it was
literally yeah that's kind of what it
was because like I said they were
printing their own [ __ ] currency like
Joseph Smith was do you know what I mean
yeah why not I mean yeah I guess that's
what he figured might as well
so yeah so Joseph Smith and his family
go to uh Missouri and they get there in
March of 1838 and a bunch of the other
Mormons followed them and so there was
like a whole bunch of them
um at this settlement that they had in
Caldwell County now he's like well we
should make a new Temple here it ain't
making me cough because it didn't make
me think about it
making me think about him well no you
came in here doing that what are you
talking about
I just swallowed funny yeah I guess you
did
so it was a Little Debbie Oatmeal
oatmeal cookie pie yeah
okay yeah
we're getting hungry
well you shouldn't have talked so much I
have something you're the ones talking
so much no I just I haven't even this
look that's as far as I got
yeah I got all kinds of food I know you
do yeah I'm just saying foreign
so yeah so they're gonna what this is
how she does me
blaming me
well you did talk a lot you're the one
that's talking more than me though yeah
because I'm trying to get through all
this stuff
I'm trying to get through all this stuff
so at this point uh yeah so they're in
Caldwell County in Missouri so he's like
we're gonna build a new Temple here
we're just like rebooting the [ __ ] so
he's excommunicates a bunch of people
that had started out with him including
Oliver cowdery who was like I said his
like second in command
um and well Oliver at this point it
actually like turned against him because
he accused him of adultery so there was
kind of like you know they were kind of
fighting so yeah so he excommunicated
him
um and also like I said everywhere they
went people that were not Mormons were
just not having it they didn't really
like these weirdos like showing up in
their [ __ ]
um now July 4th of 18
38. uh Rigdon he comes out and he's like
well hey if anybody comes and [ __ ] with
us basically what he said
we are going to have what he called a
war of extermination with hostile
neighbors so he basically said you come
at us bro we're gonna [ __ ] wipe you
out that's what he said because
apparently they were having all kind of
problems
now like I said I will say that they
were
persecuted at the time because only like
a month after he said that
non-mormons in the area
they actually tried to physically
prevent Mormons from voting and there
was like a big huge
fight you know what I mean which uh you
know which ended in violence let's let's
say
now
um after this particular incident
the governor of Missouri whose name was
Lilburn Boggs
if you can believe that that's a real
name
he basically said and this is true he
said
um all Mormons should either be driven
out of the state or wipe them out like
he basically said exterminate them or
get them the [ __ ] out of here we don't
want them here anymore in Missouri
so the governor said that
which like I said I'm not saying I'm not
a big fan of Mormons or nothing like
that but that's [ __ ] up that's a
[ __ ] up thing to say you know what I'm
saying so yeah
so um October of that year because the
governor said the governor said hey it
was okay like we can kick him out of the
state or we can kill him he said it was
all right I mean he did
so um a bunch of a mob comes and
massacres a bunch of church members at
Hansville in Missouri killing 17 people
including children
so you know
there's that so like I said they did
there was a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happened 17 people killed after the
governor said yeah we're gonna wipe the
Mormons out
so Joseph Smith gets arrested and he's
charged with treason and actually gets a
death sentence
um but he didn't get executed because
the officer that was in charge of him uh
wouldn't do anything he was just kind of
like yeah no I I agree with this dude or
I don't think that it's right that like
what you're doing to him
uh they did put him in jail for five
months though
now 1839
um Brigham Young was leading some of the
uh group here so the Missouri Mormons
they got to Illinois and some of the
people in Illinois were like yeah man
you guys are okay so they let them stay
there
now Joseph Smith meanwhile
um he is permitted to escape and he also
goes to Illinois
and while he's there he buys land for a
new settlement and they're going to call
this Nauvoo which is on the banks of the
Mississippi River about 200 miles from
St Louis
now November of that year he actually
goes to talk to the president at that
time who was Martin Van Buren and he
says hey
um 17 of our people got killed by a mob
in Missouri and that was [ __ ] up like
the governor said it was okay like to do
that uh Martin Van Buren apparently was
like yeah that's too bad but eh what are
you gonna do he didn't really do
anything I mean he said he was felt bad
about it but he didn't do anything about
it
so uh 1840 the Mormons get a city
Charter and they also have they
establish a local militia
uh so in this community that they've set
up navu uh they have a first mayor but
he gets excommunicated so Joseph Smith
actually takes over as the mayor and the
military leader of this city
within four years now Vu is almost the
size of Chicago which is
crazy to think about
um a lot of Mormons from Europe because
remember I said they sent like um people
over the like uh you know getting
missionaries like and stuff like that to
England
um and a lot of Europeans like came over
here
so a lot of them like bolstered the
population of this particular place
now in 1843 Joseph Smith comes out and
says hey I've had some new like
Revelations about some [ __ ] one of the
things was that whole baptizing the dead
thing which we were talking about
earlier like that was one of his new
ideas
um and the second thing probably the
most best known and most controversial
polygamy or what they call plural
marriage
um he's basically not only is this
allowed now but in certain cases you
have to do it otherwise you're not gonna
get to heaven or whatever especially the
women well yeah women have to get
married are you going to go to heaven
you're not gonna go to heaven yeah yeah
and you're going to marry this old
[ __ ] right here this old 85 year
this 85 year old your 15 year old ass
gonna be [ __ ] slurping up on this
that that's how they were yeah so gross
yeah yeah I mean at least like the
fundamental for sure but yeah super
gross
now um because of that whole
pronouncement like Brigham Young
um he didn't like the whole polygamy
thing
he was basically like
um yeah no I don't really like that idea
and obviously Joseph Smith's wife Emma
was like yeah I don't really like that
idea either what the [ __ ] are you
thinking [ __ ]
um but you know
apparently Joseph Smith because he
thought of everything I swear to God
like in his Revelation he's like oh by
the way like God told me that plural
marriage is okay now and I can have as
many wives as I want oh and by the way
God also told me that you as my wife
Emma you have to deal with it and shut
your [ __ ] mouth about it essentially
that's that's what that was all about so
you know
keeps wheat that's what keep that
[ __ ] sweet they always say like we
can do whatever we want to you just
gotta shut the [ __ ] up about it yeah
that's basically without be sweet take
the dick yeah
just take whatever [ __ ] we did yeah yeah
take this little damn dick you're not
allowed to complain about it no just be
up in heaven with Celestial marriage
dick in the booty
you know yeah that's actually terrible
whatever the [ __ ] it is you sing it too
sweet I'm thinking of that [ __ ] Dr
Pepper commercial with the damn dude
called little sweet remember that it was
kind of like he's kind of like
the fake Prince dancing around this I
used to like those areas
yeah a little sweet
IE those are funny though a little sweet
I like those
yeah Ben says can't have single women
run around the place hell no and Larry
creature said gotta marry the [ __ ]
Crypt Keeper together yeah yeah exactly
exactly I guess so the fat grip keeper
those dudes had a good scam going they
did they were breeding women and [ __ ]
uh handing them out man like they were
presents
like they were money well yeah well and
you build this and I'll give you this
girl yeah yeah that's what they were
doing which is like well that cult was
doing it you know what I mean like I
said I don't want to put it on the
mainstream once but you know that
particular [ __ ] woman cult was doing
all kinds yeah they were totally doing
that yeah it's like hey if you like let
me marry your 15 year old daughter I'll
give you this 35 year old lady yeah that
was at least one year otherwise remember
that was weird dude was dude already had
two wives in their 30s he gave him
another 30 something year old
for his 15 year old and I was like
there's some depreciation going on there
man like and your 15 year old your 15
year old daughter should have been worth
you know at least another 15 year old
that's funny I don't really understand
how how that
you know that that's not good it's so
gross like just this whole like [ __ ]
that's not a uh that's not a good
exchange rate you know he says well I'm
a high ranking church member you know
I'm not an iPhone you can't just like
[ __ ] trade me for some other [ __ ] you
give me your 15 year old and I'm gonna
give you this 33 year old she's used
condition but it's okay man you know
okay let me give you this mildly used
33. yeah yes yeah yeah that's what's
happening I can see the Craigslist ads
now here's her [ __ ] two children too
you take those with with her yeah that
whole mindful thing that whole mindset
is so much thanks man thanks I
appreciate it oh thanks for giving me
this raggedy [ __ ] right it was that
33 year old with her two children
thanks dude
yeah for the hot 15 year olds yeah oh my
God
that's what they were doing I know they
were like I said that's exactly what's
going on that's what they were doing we
don't think that that's what they were
they used to have a player like me in
there because I would have [ __ ]
objected to that I was just ah
I'm not taking a 33 year old with two
kids for this 15 year old you're gonna
have to [ __ ] you know you're gonna
have to match me with some other [ __ ]
here okay if they're gonna be in their
30s I want three of them you know that
he didn't even come back with that
get my counter offer say nah it's not
enough I need three of them and they
can't have any kids
so yeah
Zach says can't have women run around
womaning everywhere no no they'll [ __ ]
the place up
Larry creature women are the new trading
cards yeah trading cards Zach says she
only slightly has beef curtains 55.99
yeah
beef curtains with a touch of tuna well
it's like well you know I could just
leave her on the side of the road and
maybe somebody would like pick her up
yeah from the curb but
you know what I mean yeah let's put her
on like Facebook Marketplace yeah
what are they like what the [ __ ] what
the actual [ __ ] that is a human being
yeah Jesus Christ these women are not it
was funny is that you know look
in the universe that me and Jen come
from women don't age out at 30. okay
they were in there okay look at our
friend
hahaha
our friend Soph just hit 30. she feels
like God damn I'm getting old I'm like
well gee what is that thing about that
what does that say about me then because
I'm 20 years older though yeah but I
could be her mouth but I understand it
man when I I felt the same way when I
[ __ ] hit 30. I felt like I was
getting old too you didn't even know the
[ __ ] half of it no you're not old
really 30. unless you're unless you've
had a bunch of kids you know and you're
living out there under those conditions
that we you see there in this program
that we were talking about but anyway
yeah
that's all I'm gonna say about it
Valerian creature says you're 50.
yeah I'm 50.
and I'm almost 54. yeah times 54. yeah
yeah I'm 50 years old I was born in
1972. and uh soap's probably gonna be on
the show here uh in about a month she's
coming down don't pressure her though
like I know she doesn't like to do it
but yeah she she was we had her on the
show once before and she got she got uh
I get it everybody started [ __ ]
hitting her hitting her up on her damn
cell phone and [ __ ] and she got bashful
and [ __ ] disappeared wouldn't come to
another show again but she's
she's changed though she'd be okay we're
gonna have her on the show should be fun
I always got weirded out doing this too
like at first but I got used to it like
all those dudes started because I'm very
like introverted too but all y'all
perverts started throwing yourselves at
the damn girl and [ __ ] she's like oh
I'm getting scared she had a boyfriend
at the time
so
we'll see it is a lot it is a lot to
deal with
but she's probably gonna come down for
about four or five days I know I'm
looking forward to it'll be fun yeah
yeah she's stayed with us before yeah
um Larry creature said dude you guys
look great well thank you very much
thank you yeah but yeah I I feel it too
some days but it ain't natural I well
and the thing about it is like I don't
know I never really think about
I don't know sometimes I think about it
but it's not really that big a deal I
guess
you know
I just haven't really I never thought
about being like an old person I never
really saw myself that way no I started
going that way and then [ __ ] I
immediately started fighting that [ __ ]
I [ __ ] went on HRT and just started
[ __ ] working out I
I'm gonna be old I'm gonna be [ __ ]
hot and old and they got dudes in their
[ __ ] 80s I [ __ ] seen pictures of
them they're on HRT and do all kinds of
[ __ ] these [ __ ] 70-something
the [ __ ] looks good that if I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die like that he
wants to leave a good-looking course
it'd be a good looking 80 70. I like
these [ __ ] are seeing in this
[ __ ] in this story he's like [ __ ]
80 this I have to say I have to say that
even the young guys in this yeah still
look creepy yeah they still they all
look creepy to me maybe I don't know if
that's just because I know what they're
up to so that just like makes them look
creepy hormone supplementation people
supplement your hormones
and uh if you can afford it and there's
ways to afford it you'll see
get on the internet Zach says uh leave
her in the trash can so a neighbor can
take her like my mom took that old
Chandelier from our neighbor's trash and
restored and put it in our kitchen
that's what I mean see when I get like
too old and broken down I'm just gonna
go sit on the curb and hopefully
somebody will pick me up and put some
shellac on me and you know Jenny's still
crying really she's talking [ __ ] she's
still Prime real estate she's
it's just such a funny I don't know it's
just a funny idea to me
like leaving you outside like an old
Ikea bookshelf or some [ __ ] it's just
very funny but it's like the the way
that they talk about women that's what
it sounds like to me like they just
sound like they're well they're mundanes
let's do some Mondays and not only those
dudes not weren't sexy those those kids
weren't sexy either nobody was sexy no
they're a bunch of dorks
yeah and like not like I said not even
cool because some dorks and nerds are
cool but it's like these are like bad
dorks yeah
these are like like I said I can't hang
with people like that you got like all
these restrictions on your what are your
thought processes yeah too many
restrictions they weren't growing
properly or developing properly mentally
and physically really and they didn't
have any style
they just it was it's a shame it's a
waste of cute girls really well it's a
waste of everything it's a waste I mean
those people could just be regular
normal people these girls were talking
about got out of this [ __ ] and they're
in that program and they look [ __ ]
they look better now than they did when
they were young and they're not young
anymore they're 30s and 40s and they
they're far more attractive well okay
they were can I just they're just normal
people now and they got normal fashion
can I just say too that it's like it
really I really admire people that were
able to like especially like some of the
women that were on that show like they
were born into that stuff they didn't
know any different yeah and the fact
that when they were teenagers they were
just like yeah I don't like this even
though they didn't know any better and
they're just like they just walked out
yeah not really knowing anything about
like The Wider world or anything like
that I'm like that is really really
ballsy and the fact that they [ __ ]
did that and yeah seemed like they got
their [ __ ] together is amazing they were
being used as trading cards by a bunch
of power powerful church people and when
you look at these dudes they're beta
they're beta as [ __ ]
these Church dudes they were just
[ __ ] betas you know
it's not like these were [ __ ] Alpha
[ __ ] Predators or anything man these
dudes were a joke they were a [ __ ]
joke
but like I said it's a very isolated
well in this particular case it's a very
isolated community so it's not like
and that from a very young age they're
encouraged to not
not have self-have awareness or agency
or to have any will
yeah I mean particularly the girls they
just taught them their whole purpose in
life was to service well that one
started to question it her and her that
guy that she likes tried to run off but
then that [ __ ] didn't work out they
tried but they didn't have the skill set
to escape really and see that just
that's the problem and I was saying to
you last night I was like that just goes
to show that it's like the the [ __ ] that
they're doing is not natural or like not
right because even teenage girls that
have been that know nothing else that
were brought up in that yeah like they
get to 12 13 all this stuff starts up
they're like ew this is gross or this is
not right and they start like having
crushes on boys or whatever it is and
it's just kind of like they're like I
gotta get out of here so the fact that
even you know it's not even like they
had a normal upbringing and then they
ended up in that [ __ ] like later on they
got brought up in that that's all they
know yeah but they still know that's
[ __ ] up enough that they are willing
to like run the [ __ ] out of there yeah
they didn't make it though I don't think
uh one of them did the one day the one
did yeah I mean okay I was friends with
a girl down in French Quarter in New
Orleans this is back in the late 90s
she's a goth girl and she came from a
rough background it was abusive
and
because it was still a normal family she
was able to run
you know
and she could function
and she ran away and [ __ ] a dude that
was in his early 20s saved her she
technically she was underage though
but he didn't mean any harm by her he
was he knew where she came from you know
and a few years later she was legal you
know
and she turned out she turned out fine
but that was this is just between goth
people and normal life and uh legally
that [ __ ] it was like Hey man she ran
away and [ __ ] ended up with a dude
who was like [ __ ] you know what I
mean was of legal age and she was
illegal it was the situation she was
running from
you know
and they were just normal people I
wouldn't send that they would
if you were to get all legalistic you'd
put that dude in jail like you're
abusing that young girl no he saved that
young girl
it's hard to [ __ ] make a judgment on
that [ __ ] you know what I mean well not
everybody sucks I mean not everybody
sucks the thing about it like most of
the time most of the time people suck
like any like any time like an older
dude like saves a younger girl like that
with 99 of the time they suck and like
they're just doing it for horrible
reasons but that's not always no he was
in his mid-20s and she was in her teens
you know what I mean he had the ability
to take care of her and he did
she couldn't go back home
not with that not with that [ __ ] they
didn't really even want her back right
you know so what are you going to do
send her to some kind of [ __ ]
group home or something yeah you know
she just was this normal goth chick and
he was just normal guy well that's what
I mean not to look at the situation at
hand
and see what's going on yeah you know
yeah
it's not all cut and dried Zach says I
hope I could be on the show someday and
buck you guys you can if you want like
yeah if you're around
Zach says I Googled Mormon gay porn
earlier because how could I there was
more than gay porn and it was
interesting
gotta be terrible I'm gonna have to look
at that later on and see how that goes
Larry and creature said I thought you
were like mid-30s Jenny you freaked me
out must be no we're both in our 50s
yeah I just turned 50 last September
okay yeah
last September
um okay so where was I all right so yeah
polygamy so Joseph Smith obviously
thinks this is the best idea ever even
though even Brigham Young was like yeah
no and his wife was like absolutely not
but you know what I mean now they kind
of knew that this was not gonna fly
though because they didn't actually make
this public knowledge for like another
10 years
um you know as a doctrine of the church
is what I'm saying
but
still rumors about it got around which
didn't help endear the Mormons to the
locals who were just like oh Jesus
Christ now they're like [ __ ] marrying
all these women and all this other kind
of stuff
um Joseph Smith eventually ended up
having about 25 wives now Brigham Young
not surprisingly came around it's like
oh yeah maybe this plural marriage thing
is a cool idea
um and he would uh end up having 20
wives and have 57 children so you know
what I mean that's what happens
1844 Joseph Smith says that he's going
to run for president of the United
States
and uh he also in a sermon that he did
that year he says if you do everything
God tells you to then you can also
become a god yourself
also
um this other newspaper called the navu
Expositor has been being mean to us so
they need to be destroyed so he said
that in the same sermon so that's nice
um so this whole uh fracas that this
caused uh he also got criminally charged
for that
and uh he started to run away but then
he was like oh well never mind and then
he turned himself in so he went to jail
while he was in jail though
in 1844
uh a mob attacked the jail
and shot and killed him
and uh his brother Hiram so
no one ever got convicted for it but I
actually did not realize that Joseph
Smith the founder of Mormonism was shot
and killed in a jail cell by a mob
yeah
that's how yeah that's how I remember
yeah that's how he died
so after he got killed obviously there
was like a huge uh Power vacuum so there
was like all this kind of fighting about
the you know who was going to lead the
Mormon movement and they were kind of
like well are we gonna go with the you
know whoever survives from the Smith
family are we gonna go with whoever is
the members of the first presidency they
have the thing called the council the 12
are we going with that or there was like
some other people that were like jocking
for leadership so at this point it kind
of like went off into a bunch of
different uh factions
so basically after that
after Joseph Smith got killed in 1846
um a bunch of the Mormons not all of
them but a bunch of them they left
Nauvoo
um and they did like this big Westward
March now some of them went with this
one guy who was like a potential leader
whose name was James Strang and they
settled down in Michigan other ones
followed the other guy like uh that
Rigdon guy and they went East and they
just they went all over the place now
Brigham Young Who at that point was the
head of what they called the Quorum of
The Twelve Apostles who was like a you
know a body that was a the church
leadership he is the one that kind of
like directs this whole thing
now
um so four months him and a bunch of the
Mormons they go about 300 miles uh and
they go along like the Missouri River
and they had to wait there like for the
winter and stuff like you had to back
then
so they were kind of like trying to find
a place of their own now in April of
1846 Mexican troops started firing on
American soldiers uh who have been
placed by President James K Polk in a
disputed part of Texas so the U.S
actually declares war on Mexico in May
of 1846 and actually a Mormon Battalion
of 500 soldiers enlists although they
aren't actually in any battles at that
point now in April April 30th they
finished the navu temple and they
dedicate that
now in 1847 I guess there's kind of like
this whole uh the Brigham Young and that
whole group that he was with they got to
the Great Salt Lake Valley
now Brigham Young who is actually gonna
become like the church president later
that year this is where the Mormons are
going to be
um and because at that time Utah was not
a state so this was outside the
boundaries of the United States so it's
like we can do our own [ __ ] out here so
they kind of like mark off their land
that's going to be the temple and then
they start laying out the city streets
so you can see why Salt Lake City
nowadays is such a Mormon Haven I mean
they got there there was nobody there
they built it you know what I mean
so
that is so yeah that's where Salt Lake
City came from and that's why a lot of
them are still there nowadays
um there's also like some [ __ ] about the
gold rush I'm trying to like kind of go
through some of this stuff because we
got really behind
um but you know what I mean let's see
yeah Salt Lake City blah blah blah I
don't even remember where I was uh
Brigham Young actually got appointed
governor of Utah when uh Utah has made a
U.S territory in 1849 and Brigham Young
got appointed governor in 1850
1852 they actually publicized the
doctrine of polygamy which people were
really not
um
all that excited about so people thought
they were a bunch of weirdos at this
point in 1852 there were about 20 000
Mormons living in the Salt Lake City
area
and uh so like I said this it had split
off into a bunch of different factions
at this point because I feel like the
polygamy thing was maybe one of I don't
know if it was the biggest thing but it
seemed like it was one of the biggest
things that divided the
Mormon lay people they were just like
some people were kind of like oh yeah
that's cool but like some people were
like yeah nah we're not doing that so I
kind of feel like that was one of the
things that caused like all the groups
to Splinter off into like various other
things so like Brigham Young like he had
his thing and he didn't like polygamy at
the beginning but then like he kind of
got into it because obviously but so his
people kind of did that
but you know um a lot of people didn't
like it so they went off and started
other things like there was one called
the reorganized Church of Latter-day
Saints it's like other kind of stuff
so they also a bunch of missionaries I
don't know if a lot of people know this
but they actually set up a settlement in
what would later become Las Vegas so
I kind of feel like I don't know this
maybe is a whole show of its own but I
kind of feel like there was a little bit
of
Play Between the Mormons and the mob
like in the whole setup of Vegas kind of
thing there's like yeah like there's a
lot of something to do with [ __ ] um
a lot of that had to do with
Howard hughes's money
Howard hughes's money and the Mormons
help set up and the mob helps set up
with Las Vegas
It's Kind of a Funny connection but yeah
yeah that's what I was thinking that
city was being built around that time so
yeah there was a bunch of players that
were involved in that yeah
now in 1857 uh President of the U.S at
the time who was James Buchanan
he receives reports that Brigham Young
is essentially ruling Utah which by then
had become a U.S state as a Theocratic
domain I guess
so he's like well
um that means that this territory is in
Rebellion
so he sends soldiers out there to kind
of crack down on the [ __ ]
um now the Mormons didn't fight back
against the soldiers at first but they
did like [ __ ] with their supply trains
and [ __ ] like that however in September
of 1857 a Mormon militia
led by a guy named John Lee uh and they
also had some Native Americans uh that
were helping them out
they actually attacked a wagon train of
settlers from Arkansas and killed 120
men women and children
this is now known as the Mountain
Meadows Massacre
and like I said this happened in 1857
that was the Mormons attacking a wagon
train and I don't even think this
particular Wagon Train had anything to
do with like the soldiers that came to
like [ __ ] with them they were just
happened to be there
um they let 17 children that were under
the age of eight uh live but they killed
pretty much everybody else
now they don't really know if Brigham
Young actually authorized
this attack
but
um they do think that he
if he didn't know about it ahead of time
he definitely knew about it after and
kind of like covered up
uh uh covered it up for a little while
so you know I don't know if he knew
about it ahead of time or you planned it
or whatever but he for sure wasn't like
completely innocent
so essentially 1858 uh they have a new
governor uh that takes over in Utah and
federal troops uh go through Salt Lake
City
and the President Buchanan he declares
the Mormon War over and he issues a
blanket amnesty
however uh because a lot of Mormons were
still doing the plural marriage thing uh
they wouldn't actually let Utah into the
Union as a state for several years
afterward because again that was illegal
now in 1862 there was something called
the morel anti-bigamy act which
criminalized plural marriage in U.S
territories
um you know but president like I said
Abraham Lincoln was just kind of like
man whatever like he wouldn't really
enforce it it was the law but he
wouldn't enforce it
so a couple of years after that like in
1871
um the anti-polygamy activity like
people got really offended about it um
Brigham Young got charged but he didn't
get convicted because like I said they
weren't really
you know uh doing anything about it at
that time
now in 1875 John Lee who like I said was
uh responsible for the massacre where
they killed 120 people he became the
only individual brought to trial for the
Mountain Meadows Massacre
the first trial that they had was a hung
jury
but the following year he was retried
and convicted of murder and he was
eventually executed but he was the only
person punished for doing that like I
said they did Kill 120 people Brigham
Young died in 1877.
um yeah now in 1882 there was another
thing called the Edmonds act and that
declared polygamy a felony and was
basically like anybody who does it you
know that's illegal
so uh basically a lot of Mormons are now
you know in violation of the law uh well
sort of I don't think the mainstream are
doing that so I wouldn't say a lot of
them or most of them some
doesn't matter though
they're not looking for it well the
thing about it I mean they were doing it
at the time like some of them weren't
because like I said there were a bunch
of different sects at the time that's
kind of one of the things that divided
them into a lot of different sects
1890
um you had kind of like the church
president at the time whose name was
Wilford Woodruff and he wrote a
Manifesto that said oh basically the
mainstream LDS we they renounced
polygamy because they wanted Utah to
become a state yeah and basically like
the government was saying well you can't
become a state if you're like have a
bunch of polygamists because that's
illegal so they basically said yeah we
don't do that anymore and he officially
like renounced it so they could be a
state then so Utah got granted statehood
in 1896.
and in 1904 the church actually started
threatening anybody that practiced
polygamy with excommunication and all
and started like cooperating with the
feds to prosecute them so there's that
so by 1953
the LDS church I guess the mainstream
one had more than a million members and
like I said nowadays they have almost 17
million and that's like around the world
so yeah they've come like um like
somebody said earlier they've come like
kind of like a long way for being
somebody that was
that essentially people wanted to like
wipe off the face of the Earth like to
run an actual [ __ ] well it was just a
successful American religion it was yeah
one thing that they have done recently
that I noticed was that they did come
out because they have been traditionally
um
very
anti-gay yeah and they still don't agree
with gay marriage but they have come out
um in recent years like as was like 2019
or something like that and they
basically are like well we don't love
that gay people are getting married but
we're not gonna like kick you out of the
church anymore like you're not apostates
anymore so they're catching up with like
the modern it's the don't ask don't tell
policy pretty much which like I said I
mean that's you know that's pretty nice
for them like I said they're still doing
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] but I mean we talked
a little about about the Warren Jeff's
thing like from early earlier but that
to be fair that's not mainstream
uh Mormons and a lot of mainstream
Mormons like are really like against
that now doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] this and
that you have to understand these are
religions religions religions do [ __ ]
religions from the day one it's about
doing things that are kind of against
the mainstream culture
if it was just mainstream culture it
wouldn't be a religion religions have to
differentiate themselves
so it's just that's just what they do
it's uh I you know
[Laughter]
it's like it's like it's like I don't
expect any better either we have to have
a religion but it has to conform to
everything that mainstream culture does
well it's not a little bit don't bother
having it you don't bother having that
religion you're right yeah that's that's
just what they do
like I said I'm pretty like open like I
don't believe any of that stuff but it's
like look you can believe whatever you
want to believe
um until it starts infringing on other
people's [ __ ] and then we're gonna have
a problem if you're just keeping [ __ ] to
yourself then you know fine I don't give
a [ __ ] about you hungry yeah it's making
somebody gonna shut it down Jim all
right I didn't even get into I thought
you wanted to talk about like the dude
that did all the well [ __ ] we've been
going on for four hours no three hours
and 25 minutes yeah okay it's four bars
okay good shut it down well I guess we
don't have time to do no there's no time
for that well you know that's what
happens it shows over time it went over
time
Julia says Pat Monstercat sent me okay
okay wait you just got here yeah oh [ __ ]
he sent me he sent me an instant message
that uh people he worked with he gave
out a bunch of uh links to our show oh
okay yeah he's gonna be coming down here
soon he's gonna hang out that's good
yeah I mean I guess you'll might have to
like watch it and like watch it not live
you have to watch it like recorded
because we've been going for three and a
half hours yeah and we're kind of ready
to ready to turn it in man it's ready to
turn it in and go get something what
were we gonna watch oh we're gonna watch
we were gonna watch the the grease we
watched Greece for television live
he wants to watch that that sounds fun I
mean you know what I mean it's almost 9
30 though I'm gonna start cooking or
something all right so we're gonna go
have some dinner so thank you everybody
for dropping by I didn't get into
everything that I wanted to get into but
like I said it was yeah we could save it
for another show because it was kind of
like a lot of information to
convey but yeah so hopefully you guys
enjoyed hanging out with us this evening
we always enjoy hanging out with you
guys thank you for stopping by thank you
for all your super chats and we will see
you guys again on Friday night for the
Sidetrack show good night
[Music]